[Music]
[Applause]
uh-huh yes it's me hello dimple dabble
do but even if I knew I was screaming
obscenities still haven't as far as you
guys know hi my computer just up and
crashed on me which is really concerning
considering this is a new computer so
I'm hoping that was a temporary problem
but the only temporary problem we have
is that we have to beat those [ __ ]
once again because for some reason the
developer decided that it would be
really cool if they were like super
strong and like a big ol pain in the
dick you think about all that so we're
gonna be going back into it we're going
to be going back into it right
immediately correctly now so here we go
I love the people that are like did you
know your stream died I know I'm here by
beware of these things I can see them
when they're happening than me I can see
it with my eyeballs when the computer
crashes on me I'm here taking in all the
radiation from the dead computer in
front of me that's what I'm cooking
right now okay so we're gonna get back
into this I have to have to do the long
arduous journey because I got to go I
got to remember I gotta go to this the
bed here and then I go
out there run down Danny right up this
the way I don't know how that works with
going down in the up it doesn't make any
gosh darn sense at all to whatever I was
doing pretend like that in a but now I
got to beat this son [ __ ] again already
know that we can and one second ago Dan
little what I'm doing alright one second
I gotta make sure that ever can see
everything that I need to do and do it
correctly one second everybody
what is going on here
[Music]
there we go all right everything should
be back up and running right blue brown
blink blue blue blue baby okay so here
we go
I'm gonna beat this guy again then I'm
going to read more comments all the way
down because that's all I gotta do but
unfortunately now the videos split up
into two videos for some reason and I
don't know why it's gonna do that that
is summit that's a stupid piece of crap
and now I gotta beat this bad boy all
over again nope that's not what I'm
gonna do
actually yeah so now I gotta slap these
guys upside their stupid head all over
again which is super annoying okay
Blizzard okay but in the meantime I can
read you guys's comments the whole time
so alpha the foul ball says mark we all
appreciate what you do and think you're
an awesome guy the stream died if we
can't see a damn thing again I know I'm
aware is a Haley Dixon's hey Mark hubby
and I love you he's in school to be an
aerospace engineer Oh
anyways the stream died pump it back
soon again
I know I'm aware of these things the RAI
axis said thank you for being awesome
mark marks how mark miss you a lot there
haha just kidding love your videos has
been falling for a while keep doing what
we do love well thank you very much and
I am almost dead I don't know how that
happened but it happened
will that up as best I can oh I'm I'm
hitting my oh I'm not hitting the bat I
gotta be hitting the bat why my he only
did blind of God and forgot how to play
as soon as I can I knocked out
well alright damnit good job you did
nothing secret lady six four six says hi
mark my sons introduce me to your
channel love it you say hi to them
Maximus and Alexander well thank you
very much lion bear I am Sam out there
I'm really from the dead try to blast
back into oblivion cuz that's what's
really causing me problem see Silver Fox
you rock mark Thank You Matthew Hayes
Scott Manson I think you're amazing mark
and thanks for everything I'm done
thanks oscillator live finish I
appreciate that
ah wise Jack what did we do here
something went horribly awry because
this is going much worse than it had in
the past
alright let's just keep in them because
that bats got it I get silenced them
I didn't line them Oh they keep sucking
blood stop it stop it you [ __ ]
you're just willing to follow
died there we go God finally why is this
such a problem because now we're gonna
go into the next fight with even less
stuff than we have this time alright so
let's just do this I'm up cuz that's not
gonna do it enough so I'm gonna have you
do yeah sure let's listen to that one
cuz Bob can't blind them right now which
is the idea I am
ow again I'm knock sicut not recover
raise is going much worse than it has
before you just take a full potion you
take a dog and then you will have it it
will have any blue and that'll be good
let's see with Viper 21 cents you make
my days brighter I love when you do your
charity streams of them always done
you're an amazing person and you are an
inspiration to me just keep being you
thank you very much full potion why not
better than nothing I suppose
yeah Linds yes you wouldn't grab a
hemlock just wondering if you're going
to this anime convention that's
important again the day after you
download no I'm not gonna be in balance
that long we're in Dallas for Rome day
and then we run away from there the next
show because that's how it's got to work
until you gotta run
you got a lot of ground good even we're
not silence again the sound but we're
gonna do it again in the fall or the
winters when we're going to do another
screen that's gonna be a lot of fun
Tyler Slade says hey I just want to tell
you that we are birthday buddies you're
exactly ten years older than me to the
day
Thank You max Corrigan's very much
Bella's singer hi marki Luke can I hug
you at the show and aus unfortunately no
because it's not a meet and greet style
show so we aren't actually going to be
meeting you know in the traditional
sense of a meet up or a meeting read
this is a show it's literally a show we
have a director we have costumes we have
set changes it is
Oh because when I wanted to go on tour I
didn't want to just do a meet and greet
as we go around I wanted to do a real
show that would be something that people
would be amazed and maybe not amazed is
the wrong word that's said I got the
wrong expectations about the show but
something that people could actually
enjoy even if they weren't a fan of the
channels but I was going for and I think
oh it's no longer blinds we got to
rebind him real soon blind please
no effect now Ola its dad anyways I
guess that doesn't matter
yeah but it's a it's going to be a real
show and that's what's gonna be great
about it in my opinion that's what's
gonna be great about what motion with
van Phoenix down I've got all that stuff
good good good good for me3 down who
knows how many left
so what happens I'm just gonna go down
here and save because I don't want to
have to deal with that [ __ ] again
can we yes we can
good good good good because if we
weren't able to stopping from just
walking other than having to go through
all the horrible sand
yeah sure rest up there we go so we're
gonna say blue dusky and now we're gonna
try out for this one because hopefully
it crashes again we won't have to go
through that fight again
let's see laughing blue VD on Austin
Hazen stamp says hey Mark thanks for
making work suck less I downloaded your
videos watch them at work yes would you
ever stream any of the Dark Souls I
might I'm actually pretty competent at
the Dark Souls I like him a lot and I
feel like I've gotten better at him over
time but I've never played Dark Souls 1
at all
I've never played demon souls either so
I've only played two three and then
blood-borne which is kind of in a
similar vein but not exactly soon Dark
Souls and blood-borne are actually very
different if you ask
[Applause]
because from a technical fundamental
standpoint of gameplay it is extreme
depending Tony my sir
hey mark are you considering a killing
room stream I am I am indeed I want to
do that again um let's not do any fun
this time let's just wind him up st.
them down and blend them thank you for
that thank you for that thank you
thank you violence no not on me not on
me oh now they get blind no effect
alright great trick that's great that's
great we're just gonna Ted like we're
having a lot of fun here we're having a
great time
bang off going on that stuff it's great
let's just keep let's try to silence
them if you can I don't know if we're
gonna be able to do Sonic to solve it
all right fine one silence ones blind
that doesn't help anybody so Bob is
gonna be on constant rotation for
silencing and blinding debin jam hsiao
Dury says hi sir I'm a huge fan of you
thank you so much for your amazing
content maybe someday you will come to
India and I can be you love from India
well I would love to I would love to
travel the world just period I would
love to go like anywhere and everywhere
I want to be able to do that because
it's something that you know I feel like
it's very necessary like for people to
get a better perspective of the world a
more worldly view very stop it you were
silenced you were literally silence
Christian you were silenced god damn it
[ __ ] these [ __ ] guys are such
douchebags you just defend there's no
point even doing anything else you just
keep blinding
if they were guarding they were guarding
and you do Thomas tan it's no point of
guarding them I find you're blinded and
it's good okay you just keep smacking
you just attack cuz there's no point
guard and apparently
and I can't seem to silence him either
[Music]
okay silence is gone for yamimash
there we go no effect sorry what
well it's even the point then why was
even the point
heel to yourself the tacky then just win
them oh my god stop being such a [ __ ]
you're such a douche you do sure all
right
twin panda says well hopefully I can
make the ball show one humble due to
drag noble says hey mark sweet new prey
playthrough I need Hand Surgery though
and I was wondering if you to shout out
my GoFundMe page the name is I need a
hand that you need a hand that is
hilariously clever why are we all
silenced oh you dick holes you fricking
dick dousche errs you dick dongers you
diddle berries
all right fine I'm just gonna heal
everybody apparently cuz that's the only
thing that we can do cuz that's good I
guess this is great griping silenced
like this it's good it's good it's good
just attack him I guess cuz that's the
best that's good good sign e choose
curative silence that's exactly
going great it's go great guys go grab
glad that we get to do this all over
again and somehow even worse than it was
before cuz that's how I wanted to spend
my days doing this stuff with this guy
here
these people lovely people see if we can
just blind again try to blind them try
to try to just try to do about I know
you try but Kim Ezekiel says mark please
play markiplier ultraverse is a short
horror game I saw that one that is a fan
game too and I will do that one check is
on my list I've got a whole list of them
actually and so I'll get to them
eventually and it's just okay we're just
a it's gonna stay this way with the
blindness that's cool too
hopefully one of them dies soon cuz this
is going right
[Music]
yep that's a thing
yep dad I'm dead yet not ended Oh
finally freaky you dude prick you so
hard oh hard trick you so on silent stay
shut
Chris [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] no effect
alright god I hate you so much I hate
you so much I hate you I hate you I hate
you so much you shut it out all such a
dirtbag
bye hang out cyber banished
now sucker from a city boy so alright
keep blasting them I guess
that's right okay that doesn't even work
okay they're really fine so
q does MINECRAFT I know about one shot I
know how to do it thank you so much for
the update but I actually know how to do
it I will get to that soon
Zeebo says hey Mark let me first say I
love what that you're doing SCP
containment breach again I love the game
I do on a so do you have any plans to
play paradigm I don't even know what
paradigm is so if that's something I
then it's the first time I've heard of
it or maybe I haven't
I don't know I have no idea I'd have to
check in on that but there's a lot of
actually interesting war games that are
coming out reasoning that I kind of want
to see so I will get into that very Rob
- oh it didn't have any effect I mean
the other guys are still cycling so I
guess that's find that but even so
that's a little bit better then we'll
just a silence for the rest of forever
that's also good it's like this game is
like obscenely difficult because it's so
catered around spells right it's so
leaning towards spells such to the point
that main attacks are meaningless you
know what I mean it's a little bit of
balance but that's okay
gamecaster says hey Mark Ryan from game
castles here you're using us see you in
Indiana
June 10th love it if you check us out
we'll try a need or Ruth says hey Mark
I've been watching you since the Emmys
days and help you come to Portland
Oregon very soon I wanna go to Portland
Oregon I've heard great things about
Bordeaux
like uh I mean just in general it's just
a great place and also organ in general
is really cool
Heather Batista says thanks for the
laughs when I am sad thank you for me
kill cuz right now I'm a little bit
grumble I'm cool
it's because this guy is odd and I don't
have nearly enough cures no I'm gonna
buy a bunch of cures before but I have a
funny feeling that he's just gonna keep
doing that this is gonna keep you yep
now ever yeah all right thanks then
puppy dog 2 0 0 3 8 hey Mark just joined
the live stream fYI I was in horror
class last fall and I wrote a paper on
your finesse series gotta be anyway I
trust you with my donation but where are
the donations going Oh super tad is just
super chat that's not that's not going
to a donation I hope that's clear to you
guys super chat is just like twitches
donation system that's not a donation to
any charity just so you know we do
charity livestreams on the 23rd and 24th
of this month and we do them every month
since then you'll know if we're doing a
charity luncheon I don't want there to
be any confusion about that none at all
please don't ever be confused about that
because we are very explicit when we're
doing charity events and I the soup that
is completely optional you don't even
feel like you're obligated
no effect understand occupied what
finally he's talking great is going
wonderfully
[Music]
doesn't get fired silence and lady I
don't know if that's actually going to
work
let's see crystal relics since we are so
happy you're coming to Detroit we'll be
sitting in the very front row at 7 p.m.
that day main floor a CT row a seat 1450
and you're the best keep doing what you
do hope we get to me well you'll see the
show that's for damn sure you will be
fun cetera and you may even be picked to
go up on the show because the show is
actually centered all about you guys and
it's about you guys changing the show
and picking it all for yourself so I
think you guys are gonna see that you
guys are going to like what we have in
store for you guys live at Lucas hey
Mark thanks for all that you do and I
have great big balls dress your videos
new and old really help me eat every day
well thank you so much for watching
rust against as I mark huge man keep
doing I will because I can't do anything
else cuz this douchenozzle just doesn't
fall down to fire now a little bit more
power to that looking good blue probably
shouldn't have skipped on all the
leveling before but that's okay
no no okay don't crash my computer again
please this is the point where it
crashed it beforehand and rather and not
do that
rather it lady Elvin says why do you
always flip your camera are you can you
tell by the Space Jam um it's just by
factor of the rooms that I'm in just so
happened to be laid out so that it's
easier for me to film from the left than
it is to the right because if you'd see
the left and the right you'd see a
doorway and a wall and it's I don't want
I want you to see the wall and not the
doorway so that just makes it a little
easier
rargh rargh our ship
we're okay
praise the spirit baby
and the nanana silence you get into some
case I don't know if you're not silent
but I'm just doing it just in case
hope you're silent okay BLAP BLAP BLAP
Bobo's ski Drako Phoenix says hey Marc
I'm so happy to be able to possibly see
you June such an inspiration to hope
you'd be able to wear your shirt was
having to try and help out as I couldn't
how was your mother's day it was fine
but I wasn't able to spend it with my
mother's so unfortunately I was but I
did wish them a good Mother's Day and I
have presents and finally cure to Zek
here everybody is that what that is
Hertz benefit has to beat us again I
don't know we're better which I am this
makes me short
words
crush you no please don't I don't want
that we see
and next time
why why do you want me to die so badly
why is death such a necessity for you
come sunny - we have business to attend
to smell you idiots leader okay alright
then see you buddy I'm funny wherever
you're going playing in the rain is fun
it sure is buddy
bye alright cool
also the micromanagement of having to do
the spells each time and all the the
fights is just a bit annoying I wish I
was able to just whack them with my
normal attack and that'd be enough for
it but that would just make it boring
spacebar spamfest and it wouldn't
actually be a game in final oh so hot
why is it so hot
hi sir my last one today I wanted to let
you know that I'm 15 year old 8 years
old and I read in sale Endres Sircar
Vidyalaya I am watching you while
heating how Fonzo mangoes 13's man with
my birthday good night from India well
happy birthday that was quite the
statement bye ok shoulda brought my
poncho and sombrero
I don't own a poncho nor do I own a
sombrero oh good more equipment is
better estimates baller stuff this looks
fun yep look out we're going in dry
maximum job you can almost say it's too
hot up to him
okay that's enough what is he waived
with his buns but where's the blacksmith
it's right there right in front of me I
don't need a shout that every oh thank
you
welcome to Aaron's claim or or
Morningstar I like the sound
I don't have enough gold for everybody
[Music]
why
oh I don't care about armor at all I
don't care about armor at all
I just want two of those morning stars
yeah okay yeah okay yeah okay the magic
rubs that's something that that's almost
as good as a morning star
that's pretty good I guess maybe just a
little bit
morning star change away and then start
check plan okay good so
when you have a nice work that's nice
then you get a magic coz that's good I
guess
- baby
you have anything else
oh that's all for you okay so you have
that and I don't know if I want to get
more of those cure-alls because they are
expensive
[Music]
love a dip it down
alright fine that's it for now but if I
die out there I'm gonna be real keen I'm
gonna be real peeved thank you where am
I going the end now don't need that oh
hello
some ordinary gamers headquarters
Markham Blair hi there I'm Moody Harv
some ordinary gamers looks like he ended
up here too huh yeah I got a idea how to
get out of here you can try the temple
at the end of the desert it's a little
dangerous to get there I'll lead you
guys there if you put my channel in your
description say what now let's go
who the hell is this and why are they a
part of my team
I'll take offense to this who are you
and why are you burn your team we're
trying to sell out of my Jail huh
no no no no my man watch God watch do I
kick someone out of my goddamn team yeah
not gonna do that not God to the menu
you stay out for my team yeah yeah yeah
gosh-darn exploitative piece of
government if you put that guy before
wave we got a problem cuz ain't gonna be
your monkey ain't gonna dance for you
I'll go back and I'll redo everything
and you're not even gonna give me a
choice about that oh not today mister
not today you think you're gonna get
that huh no where's Wade
now where's the black man's worth Wade
ha ha that's what I thought
got nothing to say to me because you got
nothing to say that's right that's right
yeah
Eila go back come on quit this game
because that's how I roll till I roll
Tyrol guys it's ro
[Music]
it better not be mandatory to get that
gun on board we're not gonna do that Tim
where's my little biscuit at yeah but
where's my little biscuit where is it
you're not in it find it I'm outta here
we were never friends I thought we were
friends don't you don't you Tony
don't you tell me a guy key don't you
dear if you're dear to me I if you're
gonna be in my party I'm gonna do
nothing but make fun of you the entire
time I'm gonna mock you mercilessly I'm
gonna I'm gonna make fun of her you're
here and listen is that like the
development stuff to that maybe that's
actually the developer I've no idea
sure sure sure sure sure let's go but I
don't trust you
I'll trust you I don't like this Oh like
that's it I like this so this is sure I
guess I gotta go now
my body is ready but you stake do sit
quite don't you stay quite fun goop I'll
find my way through
I can't run here though I'm just gonna
keep going straight and forward that's
all I know how to do ow
yeah I'm gonna try to actually hit this
guy all right cool we did that ow ow hey
I guess actually oh they're temporary
party number
okay alright then that's alright they're
not actually a part of all this they're
just gonna be temporary
okay all right Jackie I got it everybody
crawl your rage everybody quad the
boiling rage inside your are just keep
it down a little bit just keep it a
little bit down I'm just trying to do
well they're just these guys because all
I just and I'm with my normal index oh
great I made innovative I made it I made
that that's wonderful thing we did seat
by your fire probably not gonna do it
was very hot here I did it didn't do a
lot though but did something oh boy oh
boy oh boy oh boy oh this is gonna be
it's gonna be an adventure isn't it
there's gonna be a riotous adventure
isn't it to the raw riotous drop in the
desert filled with death and destruction
you know at this point I'd rather this
I'd rather just you know I'd rather just
move to the boss and spend a long time
fighting the boss and spending ages
fighting each and every one of these
little douche nozzles that be my ideal
way to spend my Sunday
- Elise I don't think this get all salty
guys get a little salt to get a little
salt - can't help it Biola Saltine right
now consulting cracker right now can't
can't handle this came out was given
salty kennel so I got somebody I don't
know the [ __ ] is hanging on my back
while we're wandering through the desert
tell me like Leki's Yoda telling me how
to get through the desert and this
[ __ ] bird just won't die there he
goes finally Wow if I had to do that for
every goddamn thing that I was going to
do I'd probably just end up crawling in
a pet dying in this desert because I
just wouldn't care anymore
that probably what I do yawns it's a
conjecture at this point it's just a
wild conjecture
you know conjectures just a big world
word for meaning I don't know what the
[ __ ] I'm talking about no I can't escape
I can't escape oh that's good that's
good I did one either
okay I'm able to escape I'm to none guys
got this fun and fun it's real fun okay
fun no kiss goodbye Waldeck gun down
right that good
[Music]
Oh Ken's game oh I'm loving these games
or me right I'm loving it fine we're
gonna trick you up you do sure what's
cure do ya all sassy lines I need to
need to raise him from the dead and then
you need to fricken
[Music]
okay this nope
run there we go now we ran
so are you just here for no reason are
you gonna like not you guys that you
guys the guy the the many many random
players the guy who's with us here
[Music]
alright I'll fight you but yeah so
apparently st. does nothing
how about spark is that gonna do
something wind is that gonna do
something
Spirit bless
[Music]
yeah that hurts a lot can you not know
that didn't do much uh how I'm normal
attacks can I just do that is acting
like a new well I'll just take this
flame breath that really feels good for
me all over my skin to spray me with
your flames it's the ideal way to be in
my existence this is great what three
more of these Devils is that what I got
to do three more of these Oh couldn't
wait can't wait won't wait I won't wait
for that I'm not gonna wait for that
Rick sorry has an insulting Oh Devo
toxic said hey Marga enjoy your videos
how you liking I'm actually really
really enjoying prey turned out a lot
better than I thought it'd be and I'm
having fun of it I need to record Morgan
I'm blind I'm blind I'm blind I'm blind
I'm blind
am i blind and I am I blind ear and I'm
really blind here am i blind you say and
I'm like and I can't run from this guy
you you're saying I can't run for some
reason I just I can't run step better
guys cookies campus
Franken B ich says love me mark can't
wait to watch you get back to SCP and
thwart Billy's plans of dwara way in
domination bad Billy PS please come to
Portland organ a lot of people on in gum
for Lenore
I'll do my best no promises anymore
can this guy just is this is this this
is real life this weird issue is this
real life position this is real life
here is this real relaxed real life real
is this real life
is this really he's not dead he's not
dead yet is this real life is real life
is because I don't recall real life
being this son of [ __ ] ish so I'll just
go back to the for Chanel farm there if
that's what you want me to do if you
want me to farm farm i'll farmer right
is getting a thousand exp here every
five minutes is nowhere near as
efficient as getting and I'm going back
I'm going back I'm gonna farm because
that's what you want me to do I'm gonna
farm
imma get the fudge out of here because
I'll give you get this [ __ ] off my
back and you know what look I'm a farm
without him on my back cuz I'm gonna get
the full yeah here my name is Marcus can
wait you gonna do this again gonna lose
your skin cuz no son of [ __ ] okay so
what we got to do is we got a farm
because apparently I am too low level so
what I imagine I could do I'm going to
I'm going to go to the ice area because
I believe the ice area should provide me
with the right amount of light
investment for getting what I needed
turtle
getting gold and experience to be able
to do what I need to do so I'm gonna do
that
and then I'll be able to farm and just
non-stop read a bunch of messages from
you guys in my feeling boring in your
opinion but for me better than what I'm
that better than losing my mind in the
desert facing things that just won't die
because I think that's my problem right
now I'm probably just a bit under level
so this will fix it I'll fix it guys
don't worry I'll fix it oh oh keep
packing how's it going
get back alright good good
Bob just clap alright sorry about that
all right to the ferocity candling this
should be a good place i'ma save first
and then I'm gonna we're just gonna find
Ike honest farming sure does
okay there we go all right so daredevil
says hey Mark have been watching you for
a few years and just wanted you to know
that you're doing amazing Nick keep it
up you're awesome hizzy flyer says hey
Mark I'm a huge fan been here since 2013
I've never gotten a chance to meet you
soulfully I'll get to meet you someday
hey I really appreciate that thank you
so much oh look these [ __ ] are
trying to silence me and ain't gonna
happen that way great dragon ats is
adrian from miami florida and yes i was
gonna walk you babies thank you for
everything you've done
tribe isn't anywhere near Miami you have
fans here in South Florida to conduce
Tay Bendita when he just did a bunch of
damage to it oh wait I didn't kill up
from the last time let's see a word poll
hey mark uncreate er of presentable
Liberty and I was wondering if you'd
like to try a new spin-off game injury
are kind yes I would absolutely I would
oh man presentable zippered he literally
changed me so of course I would like to
play another game menagerie archive I
will look into that and I will play that
very soon so thank you very much
kaitlin flower said Fowler says can't
wait to see you live you helped my
sister Elizabeth so much with her
depression a shout out would mean the
world tour so hello Elizabeth thank you
so much for watching and thank you for
watching me just spinning wildly in this
forest here oh no it's a reverend I am
oh no I hope it doesn't now looks like I
got an edge with this guy Oh ice not ice
my one weakness sebou ski bushi yeah so
it is like a level thing like if people
are above a certain level you you're
below a certain level you get like bonus
things to them which is important
because if you don't have that bonus
damage then it's just going to take
forever to beat himself that's the
problem
I am extremely under level right now for
the rest of because I did that area
where I just skipped everything so once
I level up it'll be better for me maybe
and then I should be able to go over to
the rainy area and hopefully just be
able to farm stuff there again and get a
high enough level that I'm just going to
be able to blast through getting yet
getting getting 200 XP from these guys
real quick is so much better so much
better than what I was dealing with over
there so much better the only problem
over there is that I can't run which
means that I won't be able to encounter
that's a price to pay it's a price to
pay hi Roy
Yost US Air Force says hey Mark I just
wanna send some love from Okinawa Japan
bro your videos have helped relieve so
much stress and I wanted to say thank
you from the US Air Force well thank you
so much I always wanted to go to Japan I
was supposed to go to Japan then my
intestines exploded so those house uh
that was a problem um but you know just
thank you so much for watching
unattended freak sixty forces hey Mark
meet my girlfriend her name is Jorden
just want to say that cannot thank you
enough for helping us move just by
making us laugh also have you give a
shout out to Jordan make her day well
hello Jordan thank you so much Jake or
says good I markets me again I was
wondering if you could shout out my
lovely partner jasmine I think I did I
remember this she loves your videos and
doesn't know how beautiful she is I hope
you could visit I'll see some time soon
well thank you so much and hello Jasmine
thanks for watching
John says hey mark been with you since
the beginning love your videos keep it
up enjoy your Taylor cyclo psych grow
games MJG Jensen says mark you're the
best thank you for being an inspiration
to me all love from dim thank you so
much and all love back to Denmark neon
Texas hi mark really hope your tour
comes to New Jersey so I can see it
maybe meet you also on the firefighter
and your videos help me pass my down
time we love to send my company's fire
patch to you as a thank you maybe ride
to the fire truck if you're in your that
sounds really fun I wouldn't be too bad
I would love to I love riding a fire
truck i I think we're probably good
probably gonna do a tour on the East
Coast at some point I just don't know
when that might be in the fall or it
might be winter I'm not on represent
shooting and we're gonna hit the coast
but we will do we're doing like the
Midwest then we're gonna do a coast in
the coast and I just don't know we are
going to come to a lot of cities in
America then we're gonna go to Canada
then we're gonna go to Europe and then
we're gonna bring it back wherever the
hell we go next I have no idea where
we're gonna go next book we're gonna go
someone alright uh Dave ray says hey
Mark I've been a huge fan out of the
doing YouTube these two years and I want
to know if I can get a shout out yo ah
you think I can just do that nobs good
Dave phrase congratulations thank you so
much the hectic dragon markets
punishment you know that you were the
reason I could knit my life recently
not writing this for Cindy I really hope
we can meet someday and hope can give me
a shout out well thank you so much for
still being here with us that is
extremely important in it I'm really
happy that you guys are finding joy in
these videos where they can help you to
that extent stop honored by it so thank
you so much my blap-blap-blap and
daredevil a mark my girlfriend wants me
for you some families dealing with a lot
right now and shout out to where we'll
be amazing her name is Galilee Gabi
Ville agus love you mark and drag noble
with all praise Godzilla
pure lithium says whom are can be done a
chance to play and drama if so what do
you think I actually really like it I am
that chance to finish it like I said
earlier I've had this thing when I've
been able finish the games that I want
to play but it's been good
wow that guy took that a lot of damage
that was amazing good now I'm starting
to actually two criticals and stuff I
would level are we 14 16 does it show
I'll get to next level we need 6,000 all
right so we start we're starting to get
to the point where we need a lot more
experience to get to levels so I'm going
to farm in the other area right after
this battle because we ready to clear
these guys out pretty good I don't know
if you've leveled at all since we got it
it's something
it's something anyways so I'm gonna go
to the next area and try to level lawyer
and that's gonna be kid
it's so cool Tim that go go Tim don't
stay here you and all your various
clothes
Michael luck says can I please get a
shout-out for my wife Brogan walk
pronounce lucky Brogan lucky we have
been fans well since we started dating
we love it all thank you so
I really appreciated that I say we
says more I'm
marker I'm a music musician ad teacher
working on an arrangement for you of
your themes for double reads performed
by me watch out for it it will be odd
and awesome well thank you very much for
that I really do appreciate anyone that
makes like anything fun whether its
musical remixes or stuff like that I
just really don't believe this is gonna
be enough oh I forgot this kind of
[ __ ] that's just gonna poison me huh
let's see Ian Campbell hey been watching
you since sonic.exe Preedy please mark
you've helped me through some heavy
times thank you blues mark gaming will
you be playing inspired today if you do
two things it's morning completely
deceived her the first girl you talked
to is walking pattern so don't talk to
her from the left side what what is it
I've never even heard of inspire there's
so many games that come out that I have
no idea what they are or I've never even
heard of that so I guess I'll look at
that because there's something else Oh
winks girl says bugging you ever going
to continue event zero and one shot one
shot yes and that's your only I probably
will just to finish it off but I got
damn it [ __ ] this [ __ ]
alright then we're just gonna finish him
off because he's being a douche
this is the problem that I had when I
came here that's right when I came to
this area it was like this huge jump in
like the difficulty and it was only four
five hundred I was doing better up in
the other I was better off in the other
place
[ __ ] oh yeah I was better off
getting 200 at a time I'm going back and
justice that's what it was that's why I
didn't level up because it was a bunch
of dick a tree with a bunch of dead cat
ring I swear to you it's not my fault
all right here we go let's see the war
do says mark them watching you off and
on for the past three years you've
inspired me to start my own channel keep
up the good work well thank you so much
Yuki bun dog says hey mark been along
for the ride for three auction years and
can't wait from any side question what
happened to later that is Ryan's topic
on money
uh uh Cass Allen says hey Mark I make
homemade crystal jewelry and Mills
leaves and you want some day sending
videos well unfortunately I don't have a
peel box so your best bet will be one of
the conventions that I go to why is
instead on dad yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
there we go
there we go it's this just getting
brutal I would have been better off if I
were to just kept going in the desert
and fighting those [ __ ] over there
all right whatever just going to magic
yeah there was a cure
Carris is housekey says hi mark I've
been a fan since the beginning and
always love your videos we be at San
Diego comic-con this year I'm coming
from the UK and we love a chance to meet
you and thank you unfortunately this
year at San Diego comic-con I don't have
a booth I don't have a booth this year
so I don't know where I'll be because I
can't walk the floor it gets insane and
it gets troublesome actually like scary
scary troublesome anyway Michael
narrowest says nice to see some fan
games but now that I think about last
last ream i mighta mislead you I asked
about a m2r someone told me you didn't
like metroid games in general is that
true I've never said that in my life I
I've never really played Metroid games
some people may think that like if I
don't play a game that I must not like
it it's not not the case I don't not
like a lot of stuff it's just that I
often
just checked I don't have time to play
games lately so that's what I got to
deal with okay so we're getting close to
yeah we just need a few more for a few
more levels up here I'm gonna be there
some people like just are able to farm
like these types of games for hours and
hours and I'm not I gotta get through it
as best I can as quickly as of cans of
it we leave that guy's starting to take
more damage much more damage share buddy
buddy buddy buddy partner yeah
totally Dooley all right Ligonier on
boxes hey Mark been a fan since the
Slenderman days my birthday's in five
days and then in June I get to see you
more in Dallas I cannot wait to make
that four-hour trip to see you love you
man thank you so much Luna harp says hey
mark my girlfriend has been watching you
forever her name's Kira I'm wondering if
you could say huh well hi Kira thank you
so much for watching
there we go Jack's now level 17 all
right that's enough for now that's all I
do now I'm going to brave the desert I
don't have that even made a remotely
different let's think I only got a
maximum two levels there but least I'm
closer so that when I go into the desert
and I'm able to fight these other
[ __ ] I'm able to actually do some of
my life and not just wander aimlessly
and skip over all the fights cause if I
have to skip over all the fights but I'm
definitely not gonna go anywhere
and then I'm definitely gonna die
oh but now we got a deal with like
obscure lamp Ling gangway mr. bloom
Flamel dike with that equipped that
didn't I yeah I did how much more gold
boy ah have a good man mount of gold
maybe I can make something
so at least give them more defense
that's not gonna do
fire masters who might be good but I can
only buy one ago
that and
magic robes at least we'll have a little
bit of more
[Music]
ha
please okay so now that we got there
that should be a little bit for us wait
I need to sell my [ __ ] I totally forgot
about the possibility of selling why do
I always forget that that's the things
like all right this
[Music]
but I was hardly worth penance and
anything at all
let's get out there
now that we can fight people in the
desert it should just be a little bit
better for us shitty movie baby
symbol Amman to believe a little bit
about my buddy boy whatever we've been
bombing a bit mobile there we shoot me
to be able to be to be a bit of okay so
now that we're in here we can this done
all right I'll find our way through so
I'm just gonna keep going north I don't
know if it's gonna be possible to keep
going well not if that keeps happening
alright Thunderbird you want to get rekt
Thunderbird this is one-way ticket to
the wreck to zone alright Gwen Brown
says hey Mark I was wondering if you
toggles on the state's you're planning
on going we don't have anything planned
right now so you can ask and ask and ask
all you want we got no plans we do not
know where we're going we have no idea
what we're doing with our lives
everything is a mystery and we have no
plans for the future we have no way
that assessment help for you with the
Eleanor Garvey sir die mark I've been
watching since sophomore year in high
school I just finished my junior year in
college for game art I hope to make a
game that we can cry I've made two games
and sees nothing special yet thank you
that's a weird goal to have to try to
make a game that's going to make me cry
honest good luck I'm a stone-cold
bastard who doesn't feel any actual
emotions now I don't actually anticipate
that I actually ever will have emotions
any other time in my entire life I think
I'm just going to stay this way forever
Weiss is going to UM know if every fight
is gonna be like this I just ended me
now and me now and me please and me now
oh my god this is unbelievable this
unbelievable is unbelievable
[Music]
me
anything not still alive still alive
some out still life still alive it's
still alive guys it's still alive whoo
whoo whoo whoo serenity nico-chan says
long time lurk viewer your videos cheer
me up whenever I need to work on my work
have you ever heard of a game raccoon to
the moon inspired game no I have not I
am NOT trying to that's something
interesting oh we love them good that's
wonderful wonderful Thunder all right
[ __ ] this is carry on let's just keep
going through the desert I don't know
why it's decided to be such us out of a
[ __ ] what it is so what you're gonna
keep going Oh for the best no idea where
the end is that's okay
Thunderbird huh I don't want to fight
you
it's not even like a just like a
meandering like um and I don't feel like
it I don't want to fight you terrified
of this why why did why why why why must
we fight why must we fight let's see
Scott Manton says hey Mars would you be
able to give a shout-out to my cousin's
Alex and Alan acid er I haven't seen the
for ages and they love your videos well
thank you so much mayor Dec says since I
found you been a big help I suffer from
anxiety and depression and you've been a
man
help thanks for keeping me while I
appreciate you still eventually I'll be
able to beat the crap out of this guy
[Music]
easy flyer says hey Mark I've recently
been diagnosed with multiple mental
illnesses and I have also been dealing
with suicidal thoughts you're helping me
through this rough time thank you and I
just want to say don't entirely rely on
my videos I that's a very big thing to
say like and to admit on a public forum
and I just want to say very quickly if
you're thinking these things then find
the help definitely find out pursue it
relentlessly pursue help because my
videos are at the end of the day they're
just videos and the words that I say are
words from someone far off in a distant
place but there's help that you can find
machine
you're in these times and you're in
these struggling times are you having a
lot of trouble then find out let go find
help it's so important to get help and
take that step to admit that you need
some help if you are having these
thoughts because it's that's a that's an
unbelievably serious thing to say to
even have thoughts about it is just
undeniably serious you have to take it
seriously more so than just watching
videos because that's that's self
medicating in a way and self medicating
isn't going to give you many there's
some things that thing that you need to
have help for absolutely everything your
life there are certainly a lot of
problems that people need to tackle on
their own and that's fine that's totally
fine I understand that like I hold
myself accountable for a lot of things
too and I want to make sure that I'm
able to help myself whenever I have
trouble but that is so Suze
like please like I and I know you're
probably already getting out but
definitely definitely devil there anyway
that's the only spell out button it's
just that to me those Sunday Times so
series and so cool and need to be
addressed
with like the utmost respect not saying
yarn treating it with respect diving
adjusted so Anna Matt to see access hi
mark I want to know I want you to know I
think your awareness a person any I
don't want to seem rude but it's
impossible to come think about coming to
plane while Michigan nothing happens
here I know everyone would love it
why would everyone love that that's not
what everyone would love now is it uh uh
yeah but no I in my goal to travel the
world I'm sorry I won't
there's too many cities and I have no
time to think about Rangoon just recover
its awesome ocean
[Music]
restaining says hey mark just want to
say that you've inspired me in my life
to not give up on many things like my
drive would be an environmental engineer
also you taught me not to give up my
alcoholic then well I'm glad back and do
not give up because there are some
things definitely then you need to see
through this to the end not to make up
or comparison to what you were saying
but that's what I'm gonna do to this
game I'm gonna see it through to the end
and that's what I committed to and
that's what I'm going to be doing so I'm
definitely going to be getting all the
way to the end there you're dead now yay
water was learned I don't know what that
does I can make water now which I assume
means I can piss my pants
hi drink how you doing been a while what
does water do just water damage to one
end let's see what it does let's see
what it does I don't know what he's
gonna do but let's see let's just see
I'll wait I remember one of these
attacks don't do ditch No
no same-same doesn't do there that's
right st. doesn't it
okay so st. that's good because now I
have something else and then you can
just do recover I guess sure and then
you can do with don't oh I forgot oh no
oh good good good good good good good
[Music]
levy blaze hey Mark my wife and I love
your videos can you say hi to her her
name is Cassidy just for her to see this
she wakes up well hi Cassie thanks so
much for watching
blab blab spirit up flap I'm just gonna
beat the [ __ ] out of everything here
because I'm glad that you guys are here
to like you guess you're committed to
watching the stupidest I want to get to
the meat of the matter of this game and
and unfortunately unfortunately the one
biggest criticism I'll say about this
game is its it's supposed to be a fan
game right it's supposed to be a fan
game and I'm not saying things can only
be a fan game you can make it you can
make fan games and try to make a good
game around it too and I think that's
what they tried to do but also they
relied
on the combatants in to the point where
I have to farm experience and I know
it's like it's kind of built in so that
it's a it's on the journey kind of thing
but also at the same time it's kind of
not it's kind of not it is kind of like
you have to farm and you have to kill
this and it's an are do a thing and it's
a little bit dragging and it takes away
from the fangame aspect of it because
the story is lost in the combat the
combat has no plan the story
these creatures mean nothing to the
story these creatures mean absolutely
nothing so when it comes down to when
I'm playing this game there's a very
little like things to actually do you
know what I mean it's like it's just a
bunch of placeholders that keeps me from
getting to where I want to go and and I
don't often criticize fan games like
this but given that I played a lot and I
realized full well what the limitations
of some are and some aren't like I I
just want to say that like it is in fact
taking away from the full experience of
me playing this game by having this much
combat now this is the first of the
trilogy they may have absolutely
improved methods based on criticism for
this game because I would definitely
criticize the slow pace of because
as you can see if I was to ever do a
video about this I would be hindered by
the fact that there is so much combat
because it takes so long to get to the
meat of the matter but that's fine it's
okay it's not that bad I'm just saying
I'm still committed to go through this
whole adventure and I'm still committed
to be here till the end of my days but
for now I'm going to be slogging through
this is when I can just say just say ah
there we go the desert is looping find
the way out
how does someone say all praise God's
own okay so I was just about to say that
I thought things look familiar there so
I'm pretty sure I I got to find a way
out so I will look for that in the next
adventure
come on just fall over already
baton Jack's face whoosh oh geez oh geez
it's like when I actually pay attention
to how much little I'm doing to this
thing there we got more experience
okay so that it is looping so there is a
way out somewhere look that is so
annoying it's so annoying that I can't
escape now like that is the biggest pain
in the dick right now same works on
cover same
as he days Oh Ali lark a market been a
fan since elusive witches were first
blacksmith actually came from
thanks for the laughter over the years
they've had me through some rough things
who created the laughs and helped others
laugh for more years to come thank you
so much Courtney Skillman says thank you
for being a bright part of my day even
on the darkest days thank you so much
for watching
chase Ryder says hi Mikey montemor hope
you keep doing what you do helping cry
these people thank you so much thank you
for loss and I'm gonna talk about calm
because I my voice is actually getting a
little bit tired my fellow on to record
today and I've got a lot left on this
game so we're gonna turn this into
Podcast welcome everybody
[Music]
stupid lizard tail above our consumer
affiliation all those resources but
under anesthesia lines in concealing
what to use water because in case of
Japan
[Music]
most famous sketches in
thank you so much for that I actually do
people actually because I know it's such
a man we will then demand
incredible
[Music]
but if people actually thought like I
could sleep think about that because I
as much as in I wouldn't do a straight
unboxing but I have had this idea in my
mind about doing a funny version of an
unboxing video and I can no any bone but
I just don't know if it's um
[Music]
in sauce says it is fine to say please
never underestimate the encouragement
thank you
I definitely don't underestimate and I
don't think that everybody is if there's
no Hazen important statement and I'm not
saying the people are my things help
doesn't end there I know they're my
videos
I don't intend to
[Music]
what I'm saying is it like my goodness
wasn't a giraffe are important but yes
they are temper heart
comes from within literal
since posted there go sorry the game
when they crashed before I think gave me
[Music]
these fun games and what I said
experimentation fun to inspire a
multiplier fan game which is my game the
sequel is going to be a mega deal for
you okay
so I will I will look into that I didn't
know it was I do want to do mundane
things I don't know how your live stream
fundings on this one when I saw this
game live integrity to actually be like
a regular multiple our fan game and
something thing was going to be I was
going to be able to finish off in just
one one one session here but this is
turned into a lot more than I thought it
can be because I find that it was going
to be three to four hours of actual
gameplay nights three to four hours of
beating up birds in the desert which is
totally fine that you to do not bad at
all but yeah nobody is that better for
the volume because I turned it down to
about half of what it was before I know
that I'm talking quieter ah
[Music]
fun it's just beyond this pass we're
always here says the dick all right
not the deccan of love stop being mean
lega let's see steam cover some ethers
around now we're not actually we're just
gonna go and I know that they're gonna
be even more encounters here I'm never
gonna get away I'm like never gonna get
away as far as the eye can see just
going to be this this stupid battle
music till the end of my days
thank you to the wolf Adam Gravelle says
hi mom could you do a shout out for my
friend and allene who loves your channel
and will be leaving for Germany in the
next University work and everyone at si
D mi C will miss her well shout out to
Anna Lee no not that
hello from Scotland says Katherine
Paterson love the British accent mark
hopefully my fangame death by references
is on that list of yours I'd like to
know your honest opinion on fanfiction
eg non romantic stuff I'm fine with
fanfiction I actually there was a time
in my life and this is a little bit
embarrassing so everyone start recording
this there was a time in my life when I
prayed the first Mass Effect I was such
such a big fan of the game I was such an
enormous fan of the game that I actually
read fanfic
not like not like the romantic stuff
either just I I went to fanfic
fanfiction.net was it fanfiction.net and
I read fanfiction about mass effect and
I was so it my god with three steps you
[ __ ]
you're such a game developer you're such
an [ __ ] alright ai-ai-ai-aight uh was
it April hi I yeah I listen to a lot of
I I read a lot of fanfiction and that
only lasted for the first game I'm not
even a walk I don't know I've never done
that for any other thing in my entire
life I've never done that I've never
been that much into fanfiction but just
for some reason that game I was like I'm
so annoyed that I just had leaked more
and even when Mass Effect 2 came out
which was by far my favorite Mass Effect
game I played the crap out of that one
but AM for that one I didn't read
fanfiction I was I just enjoyed the I
just played the crap out of the game I
played the game over and over again got
every single possible in yeah so so you
guys got that on camera and everybody's
happy about that so I don't mind
fanfiction and although just answer the
actual salinity says hey mark please
come to Buffalo New York for the top
food cities in the US were the city of
good neighbors and have tons of escape
rings have you ever done one before if
not you definitely should I do want to
do an escape room I do I do I definitely
do and oh my god we are doing so
terribly
okay I have to really I got a loop
through this whole goddamn mountain with
monster encounter after monster counter
I think I think the developer must know
at this point but for some reason they
didn't patch it they didn't fix it
because it would have taken too much
work to actually what change all the
values of the game to make it so that
this was in a bag of douches which it is
it is one under centerpiece and
conditions I've ever seen in my life
okay Francis McCarthy says mark my
girlfriend I've been watching for years
now who love you please give her a shout
out she will cry with happiness her name
is Abby hello Abby
Luke meddler happy birthday they're
turning 18 uh jet the wolf said lo
forgot to leave a message I'm a huge fan
work I'm glad you picked up games like a
CP you should check out the full of
Silent Hill al Camilla now that is a
blast from the best Silent Hill alchimia
that is that is um it's not an official
Silent Hill game but it's a game that
came out a while ago that basically man
I can't even remember what it was about
I played the demo thing that's so long
ago I just can't remember what it is
about anymore I mean what was it about
like I can't remember what the story of
it about but the demo came out like
three years ago I played that ages ago I
didn't even know that the full version
came out so that's something that's very
interesting
my goodness these guys are so oh we got
a triple level up I guess that's
consolation prize can't even strengthen
mark wait a moment
why what's wrong yeah me tired I just
need a break that's all Oh what excuse
me um it miscues me uh excuse me what
that Bouldin really rocked his world
it's really the time yeah man ouch him
what the [ __ ]
come on gentlemen we must keep going
let's not let his sacrifice go in vain
what did he sacrifice he didn't
sacrifice [ __ ] he got crushed by a rock
what what so what I'm down a member oh I
have to fight these [ __ ] down a
member with us some smelly gamers with
me oh what a bunch of dick they they
killed yamimash Tippi put into the party
they killed yamimash Oh
oh no oh no oh no I see what you're
doing it oh boy
and I can't even control them they're
just gonna be there doing their thing
and probably doing it let's see what
they do let's see what they do cached
[Music]
it's okay they're just throwing shade
because I'm throwing shade at them
whatever it's fine it's whatever I'm
going back to radio markiplier hey
smooth time dude [ __ ] on this guy this
isn't the developer the game I don't
know I'm just kidding I don't mean to be
mean about any of that but I can't
believe it they were just straight-up
kill yama is like that why what's the
point of that was there a point for
their format is there a point to that
but honey alas it is not for me to
decide they are defeated parties
victorious and all of this was for
nothing
can I please go in this cabin it looks
freshly collapsed why would you put in
fake games why would you do that I hate
you so much I hate you so much I hate
this this just absolutely ridonculous
but it's okay I'm going to be a strong
non bubble blowing baby about this I'm
going to be a hundred percent on board
for all of this and I'm going to a up a
for as long as a is okay in here why why
wouldn't just straight up
Nicholas because I say but at least
they're pullin marry that's the only
good thing I can say about some slimy
Slough slurs it's that they're pulling
their weight they're throwing a lot of
shade here they thrown a lot of shade
and now you know it's alright you know
it's alright it's okay yeah
brown eyed psycho watching this makes me
glad that my fan game has no battle
system this is reminding me of dream wxe
for me I think an unboxing video is good
whether normal or funny do what excites
you I actually you know I have a lot of
a have a lot of ideas I I'll just say
that much I have a lot of ideas about
what to do and I need is about games to
make and III are games to managing
zooming videos to make oh finally quick
God oh please tell me light the bonfire
please and then apparently we're going
into this game find whatever it's fine
it's fine not gonna complain about
anymore can we please leave
I'm scared sure we can no don't pick too
long alright fine then well aren't you
guys a sight for sore eyes Oh mark good
to see you my friend
[ __ ] I mean you guys got here already
yeah why are you guys acting so weird oh
yes there's no sentient hiding it is
there hiding what see I'm not a knight
and we're just two young men stuck here
with everyone else we've been having
some problems taking care of the
Guardians it's why I'm glad that you can
carve through them so swiftly I wanna
send via good cover
shut up tereus
[Music]
okay then anyway step aside I have a
score to settle what happened
this [ __ ] killed poor yamimash oh I'm
sorry to hear that I don't want any pity
I just want to avenge yamimash then who
are we to stand in your way let's keep
moving Aries all right then
Roger but first you might need these
what I received a hi-potion sweet Oh
received an ether
good luck friend Thanks i'ma save after
that long-ass speech and we're gonna go
in there now we're gonna get them good
now we're gonna really bang dank deulim
we're gonna smith's ma'am that's ma'am
Smarr we're gonna flim-flam the flinging
out of them are you sonot you better not
come back that's all I gotta say about
this oh this is going to be up the start
of a fight
oh there's gonna be such a [ __ ] alright
whatever I'm gonna try to hit all of
them we're going to take out the
Thunderbird first fire - I didn't even
know we had fire - holy [ __ ] we just
learned that that's gotta be on here
all right holy balls holy holy holy
balls balls holy holy holy balls oh that
did nothing I forgot that there
fire-resistant God what is even the
point of this all right wait I forgot
the Thunderbird dude the Thunderbird
just revived health or did it not I
don't know I wasn't paying attention to
that I wanna see them that did good okay
fire - did nothing so Blizzard should do
a lot maybe come on hurry up hurry up
hurry up all right
yo p-chan Salang see says hello mark I'm
so happy you're coming to Dallas and
Houston Texas can't wait see you then
notice me well too late I did yeah they
just took damage search fine but the
middle guy is immune to it it's fine
their immunities are so weird they're
all over the place with them all right
we're gonna hit them with I'm just got
to do water for now because we're gonna
do single-target stuff to them to
recover no nap time listen Bob stop
being a coward Bob and come out cover
yes still good douche
Zachary Burnham says I noticed that you
and other youtubers are especially
jacker able to reach people who are
hurting emotionally why do you think
that is
[Music]
um I've always just been the type that
wants to spread a message of positivity
and that's basically all I've tried to
do whenever I do YouTube and I I think
that does just generally resonate with
people like that
that in and of itself is important just
to have the idea that you can you can be
okay like it's possible to be okay like
just sometimes people just need to hear
that and that alone is enough to keep
some people going for I'm not saying
that's for everybody but for some people
like just the idea that there is hope
can be enough to keep people going like
the difference between someone who's
like falling off the wagon with someone
who's sticking on or clinging on to it
is sometimes the difference of just a
little bit of encouragement that's why I
find it so important just to like when
you're going out in your normal day just
to like go into someone and say hi
complement them be nice to them like do
something that helps someone you know
and just kind of like give that you know
give that message of hope that it is
there and that could it's important you
know it's it's something that can help a
lot of people if you just do so it
doesn't take any any any time out of
your day it doesn't
you just do it scan that's all I gotta
say about that I wish I wish more people
did it I mean a lot of people do and a
lot of people all you guys definitely do
and that's something that's super
important to me and I don't think that's
lost but I'm I'm just you know I I
sometimes want more people to you know
just be a part of this be there for
everybody music yes because it's not
just me it's not just me that is there
for people it's takes everybody we're
all in this world together yeah
here for each other that's just the
bottom line we have to cuz there's no
other option you know what I mean yeah
anyway so now that this guy's silence
hopefully that's gonna go pretty easier
although he probably has Eagles and
noodles of the Lucia Fire - oh [ __ ] this
guy water water it's a real good shade
hurt some real good fire hurts and that
fire heals and fire yielded okay no fire
no fire fire bad fire bad all right
flap flap you're gonna do wind let me
see if that works
yeah that's not one thing like I'll say
again I hate the fact that not only is
there a combat system but it's a combat
system that is entirely reliant on
abilities not just normal attacks which
I you know in the meta game of most RPGs
that's the way it goes anywhere but can
I go a little easier on me and that was
it that when they said dream dot exe was
was the thing
[Music]
let's see crimson creature said hey Marc
just wanted to say I consider you to be
one of my best friends also your logo is
tattooed on my left shoulder stay being
the awesome guy you are you stay being
awesome we need to heal jack
[Music]
I don't wanna I don't wanna heal what
are the odds he's gonna hit Jack again
what are the odds what are the odds I
think he's tough he could take a hit
maybe whoa that was close one all right
jack you you heal yourself with a full
motion whoa hi potion but what's the
difference winning hi-potion in a full
potion what would you use one another
that's stupid
okay whatever it was fine if this guy
could just die that'd be great gentlemen
Rose says the Omar keep up with all the
hard work if you came to San Francisco
for yeutter I'd be the happiest and
first person to buy tech slope Robert
Walker says hello mark I want to thank
you for being you I want to thank you
for giving me an so much joy and
laughter in my life may Jesus bless you
well thank you so much for that and then
dragonus sensor says you're an amazing
person mark I love watching your videos
and I've been creating them myself
because you inspired me keep being
awesome I will do my best as soon as
this as soon as his son of a biscuit
falls over and dies I will be as awesome
as I can be
[Music]
does an endless slog it's an endless
slog that's the only way to describe it
this is a slog this is like a raid boss
in world of warcraft boss fights would
take ten minutes this is taking longer
than that that's my problem
how's my problem
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah the only problem is I'm actually
running out of time I'm actually literal
I'm legitimately running out of time so
I think after this one I'm probably
going to end this episode here just
because I've no time to keep going at it
so her ended here I wanted to finish
this I wanted to finish this I would
have if I had more time oh my goodness
it is taking so long you know what
actually I could I could technically
[Music]
just keep going with this I could I
could technically do that and it
admittedly admittedly I don't want to
say I don't want to quit I don't want to
quit because I after this I would be
more than halfway through it but if it
was going quick at first and then on
this one it just like somehow stopped in
its tracks everything just became a
nightmare but okay you know what
actually I can move stuff around I think
I can keep going with us and I think I
can finish this out I think I can I'm
pretty sure I can I'm pretty sure I can
I think I can yeah I think I could God
Scott I guess sent a text actually
that's an insect's
[Music]
ya know what I'm gonna do that I ain't
gonna give up on this I ain't gonna give
up on this I'm gonna finish this and I
want to see it through to the end unless
my computer crashes again and then I'm
gonna take it as a sign from the
universe that I am not supposed to
banish this but whoo whoo whoo boy oh my
god sorry excuse me I have a standing
desk so a lot of people don't know I
actually knew these standing but I've
been standing for like three hours
straight now and it's starting to get to
me let's get my spine it's just starting
to came in on itself watching this
repetitive [ __ ] go over and over
again endlessly looping endlessly
forever and ever forever and ever ever
[Music]
yes finally Oh finally and that's all
the experience that we get that's all we
get all we get that's all we get two
levels and that much experience and
that's all we get that was for yeah me
well now that [ __ ] dead I'll head
back to my house see you around
alright bye then thanks for nothing you
didn't actually help us in any way you
literally didn't help us at all
and yeah me died for nothing I'm not
going to do that just in case I'm gonna
save because holy [ __ ] I'm not doing
that again I'm gonna save and I'm gonna
get the Fuji Fuji out of here just in
case mr. sandy Chiu decides to pay me a
visit
save and then stay right here rest at
the bonfire yes yum yum yum in my tum
tum I feel so much better like it so now
we're gonna go up there and we're gonna
tell ya let's see
Tiger king 47 hey Mark since you
mentioned it mind giving the market
peeps a shout we all appreciate you and
everything you do the market beeps if I
believe are my guild on on World of
Warcraft which I have not been able to
play I readily admit I have not been
able to play and I feel bad about it but
I just I just I don't have time to do
that and everything else that I want to
do so there's a lot of stuff that I
could do but unfortunately no okay so
there's just two more two more and
hopefully that's done leafy foxes hey
Mark my name is Ezra and I've been
watching you since you've been a babby
youtuber could you get my BF Alejandro a
shout-out that'd be awesome thanks you
rock shadow tell home thank you so much
I got the rocks out of the way but I'd
still stay away from here if I were you
no I gotta go in here I gotta go to the
convection crater I don't I don't know
why are you [ __ ] kidding me you can't
be serious yeah I'm asking the same
thing myself because I wonder what I
bring ow ooh my tootsies
I'm not burning alive right now ah good
Mount Olympus ascent ah good yes
wonderful hopefully I don't get crushed
by another rock is that what just be oh
so terrible
I've only got three people
how's this gonna go well let's try to
fight one of them and let's just see
what happens
[Music]
this is gonna be this is going to be the
greatest test that I have ever gone
through isn't it it's gonna be the most
the most enduring test ever in my
history on YouTube finishing this
goddamn game and I bet I bet I bet he's
gonna be so unbelievably difficult to
beat this is so unfair I just I go
through periods where I didn't realize
how unfair this is how does stupidly
unfair it is I did the ridiculously
unfair it actually is like I just I see
it for what it is I see it for the
Doosan tree it is is a condemned
nightmare it's so unfair
just get blinded I think Oh oh man
[Music]
all right did I not heal anybody did
that just not happen oh raise that's not
what I meant to do oh I meant to do
recover or whatever
I forgot you had recover not not the
other one I didn't I just ended up
raising absolutely nobody Oh No Bob's
gonna die oh no about didn't die
shockingly Oh that was not worth it
not even close to worth it oh man all
right I'm just gonna try to run from
every encounter and if it takes me 10
million tries to run then my god that's
this one's gonna be because I there we
go yes you do that for every one of
these sons of [ __ ] and just let me
get to the end of the goddamn game and
we're gonna get along just fine
nope that's a dead end because of course
the developers putting in dead ends why
why wouldn't they nope then escape that
time oh is it because because it because
my agility is down is that what it is
because I equipted the big-ass Claymore
or the the mace there we go
there's infinitely better than just
trying to fight those douches please no
please no aah
some neighbor
I'm dying guys died died there we go
I'm dying guys I'm dying please help me
somebody help somebody help me I'm dying
it's gonna be a trick is it mmm Ponzi
kitten hey marks thank you for being a
ray of sunshine you really are one of a
kind
well don't know if I'm being super super
ray of sunshine now that I'm being beat
down upon by this chimera endlessly and
over and over again
woof on the way they actually had the
way be the first way I can't believe
we're actually doing this
we need Lynx fire tunic if you can't
stand the heat get out the shot up Bob
you won't shut about bet your stupid
blacksmith she cut to my core
he knows my deepest darkest secrets oh
hello
oh that's it a bonfire a bonfire that
was the only reason that
you keep digging with me I don't like
that hmm no no like that at all I don't
like that at all I don't like that no
one did EBU not one bit EBU and also
like the problem is there is no easy way
to get experience and I just end up
sucking sucking a lot of big all the
time huh
le in the gram said hey Mark had been a
subscriber for multiple years and I
wanted to ask your help for my third
attempt at raising money for child's
play I uploaded a video on my channel
would you mind helping everybody please
go check out le & Graham's channel to
see that video about raising money for
child's play uh and the thing about the
thing about a charity you say third
attempt does that mean you you you
didn't do it before because any attempt
at charity is good like if you have a
goal and you don't hit a goal don't feel
bad you still raised money for charity
that's the most important thing above
all else like that that period is the
most important thing oh my god can you
not cast tornado your most fun can you
not cast your most powerful spell Bob's
knocked out and of course then I escaped
after Bob gets knocked out eggie hate
this I hate this I hate this I don't
hate this game I hate the gameplay I
hate it I hate it this is something that
actually I really dislike it's just it's
it's a [ __ ] fire dragon sure fall
finally I'm able to escape just like
that ah man but this is like
legitimately I hate this I hate this
it is obscenely like annoying that's not
that's the only word that I can use to
describe it is annoying Anna and I know
that there's no point in continuing to
hammer the party hammer the thing that
it's annoying I know I know it doesn't
help anybody that I keep talking about
it but it is it's frustrating it and now
it's sunny chew on
oh man it's it's just is it just is
plain and simple annoying and
frustrating I don't think there was
enough play testing done for this
particular game I just don't think it
was because it would have been obvious
to anybody that plays it that it's a
frustrating experience it's it's an
uphill battle the whole way and it's
getting slower and slower and the the
curve for experience and damage and
health has gotten to a point where it's
not good enough and it's becoming more
rewarding to just skip the encounters
than actually try like that's the most
unfortunate thing it is worth my time
more to try to run away than it is to
actually try to fight this
what is burst I don't know what that is
all right malaria all right that is the
last time I will complain about the game
that is I swear and that is the last
time I'm gonna complain about the game
unless I die from these guys wait oh
it's Wade well there is Mark you two
again oh great well as if it is it
monkey plier and his boyfriend's come to
play oh goodness this isn't over
Wow what was that for did wait could
beat the [ __ ] out of you and for you I
don't have time for you this time
but next time we meet I'll make you
regret ever following us around okay
cool
thank you let's get you neat you let
these mug lemo folks get beat up by that
stupid statue inside their temple yes
Father
you okay Wade I've been better
who are those [ __ ] the biggest
douches in the universe at least they're
gone now I guess what happened I was
just walking along exploring this place
when I stumbled across this weird cave
then these guys came out of nowhere and
started attacking me so wait wait you're
telling me you're telling me you're just
you're just exploring on an active
volcano you're just adding about what do
you love Eva I don't have okay no okay
do you know what's in there yeah some
weird statue in a glowing light if
one of the keys well come with me wait
I'm gonna need your help okay I guess
all right what can we do and also what
level is week level 20 that's the what
level I'm supposed to be I'm supposed to
be level 20 I think oh well but what do
you have confusion yeah you do
poison breath breath alright you know
I'm down for that
I'm down for that I'm down to poison
them oh it's up on a fire yes please
light it and I hear a Timmy Tim bouncing
OLC who's killing Timmy's bouncing
onesie hello are you up there
well where are you with oh there you are
okay so I'm gonna say before I go to
that boss which it allows me to do
thankfully also love the fact that I'm
in a pit of Hell here
thanks Tim take care of yourself mark I
will maybe we'll see about that
huh don't know when there's gonna be a
Drake in a chimera here or a [ __ ]
dragon alright here goes nothing looky
yeh look at that there's so many of them
I hate them all hey hey hey hey
take them all hey hey hey hey hey hey
take them all hey everyone here everyone
that's stupid alright so let's see about
this I'm gonna
what is going on here let's see about
damaging all the enemies let's see about
raising spirit for me let's see about
blinding everybody and let's see about
confusing everybody because if
everybody's confused confusion means
that they'll attack each other hopefully
I don't know if that's a hundred percent
true no that's the first time you've
ever done that that's the first time
you've ever done that why would you
suddenly do that now no effect no effect
oh [ __ ] off no effect confused no effect
at least the Guardians confused I'm
confused spear it up man this is going
to be Oh take that oh yeah oh yeah all
right so this is good I guess so spark
was fine you're blinded so just keep
spirit upping everybody get Bob up there
try to cast silence and add poison
breath to the mix if you nope nothing
okay that was useless why even bother
why even bother
BAM okay so the guardians immune to
lightning so we might as well silence no
effect no fact nothing what is even
goddamnit
alright so I'm just gonna keep doing
spark because it hits two for the price
of one so you might as well you recover
you try to sleep I'm I guess we're gonna
try to confuse them again because if I
can get the others confused then they're
just gonna keep hitting each other
hopefully clear everybody out because I
know they can be confused no effect
magma Guardian is fall asleep I don't
know if that's what I wanted no effect
no effect god why it's so annoying when
these things don't actually work let's
see Rena Moody hey Mark you're amazing
the stream is making me kick 'old so
much please continue it's amazing
hilarious good luck finishing it all
need it I don't know why this is making
you giggle do it I'll take what I can
get I guess all right let's keep
slapping them slapping as hard as we can
slippity slap I'm just gonna keep trying
confusion over and over and over again
because the opposition is just like what
else would we do
ah ah you're confused now good good good
good good
oh okay all right then good good good
huh woke up did you alright so we're
just gonna try to yes yes this is
exactly what I wanted okay I'm gonna try
to we're gonna try to get chimera one
down as best we can we're gonna we're
gonna actually spear it up Wade so maybe
he's gonna be able to be a little bit
better about this Blizzard and then
we're gonna Life Drain maybe I don't
know how much the Zags gonna do and
these guys it's good thing these guys
can't hit anything else they kill
themselves Jack is cured blindness Life
Drain not bad not bad at all that was
actually a good amount of left rim uh
what they're immune to a blizzard
they're immune to a [ __ ] blizzard
this is [ __ ] [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
[ __ ] I tell you alright fine then
we're just gonna keep trying to poison
them I guess other so confuse are they
so confused
oh no effect no effect ah
someone got poisoned alright this is
going better he's going a little bit
better I'm feeling a little bit better
about this not a lot better o get rekt
batch the chimeras
there see and then more confusion just
more in to sow the seeds of confusion
all over the place
endlessly endlessly endlessly come on
yeah yeah okay that's all we needed we
just needed a big guy confused because
the big guy is the one that's really
gonna dish out the damage okay so let's
just kill the chimera so that we can get
the big guy hitting himself real life
ground on that chimera oh never mind is
gone okay get me into Life Drain so
that's interesting ah okay so I just got
to keep it confused just got to keep it
confused
[Music]
yeah clumsy kitten says oh wait you've
helped me through a lot you push me to
try my best every day Thank You marking
me well thank you so much really
appreciate that hope you guys or hope
you're doing well where you are keep
throwing keep throwing confusion Adam
Paulo Randolph says hi mark me my
girlfriend love your channel thanks for
the laughs enjoy you brought us I'm
proposing newer and hoping that we could
have your blessing and a shout out well
I guess is she watching this right now
did you just ruin the surprise
no if you did I don't know if you did
but I'm sorry if me ringing that out
loud ruined everything I apologize I
think also yes black blessings upon you
my blessings all over there
it must already be confused I must have
missed them I was reading it BAM
oh yeah man it just only hits itself
once and it's gone keep confusing it
please ah
no he's gonna hit one of us all right
Jessica Hanley said the world is lucky
to have a man like you and it you
inspire me and others everyday I would
love if you could read bedtime story
someday with your dreamy voice sad now
something that I thought about but I
could try it
a shalyah says hi mark honestly I
finally catch you on live yeah slow
literally waiting for the right moment
to send this off to you so you can see
it love you
Crowley gameplay says hi mark I'm
challenging you to a scroll off I will
overthrow your reign as king of the
squirrels for I am the true squirrel
King okay sure yeah everyone believes
that you know it's a democratic system
some people gotta vote for their king so
I don't think you're gonna even come
remotely
to getting to where I is so sorry about
that
I'm already okay you hear about for me
to be king of the squirrels oh yeah try
I thought everybody everybody I thought
though yeah I thought that much oh oh
you're so soon eh oh no you're dead
alright so they're dead everybody
leveled up which is good can you get
bone what the hell is that that's what
we've been fighting all day to get these
stupid keys what are the keys for
hopefully to open the castle door so we
can finally find to defeat the king and
finally we're home seems too easy shut
up Wade you don't know what you're
talking about weed but I do come on talk
to Tim it's oddly quiet in here take
care of yourself mark I will now that
I've been the Guardian I think there
isn't much left anymore maybe one at
most maybe maybe one maybe maybe one
maybe come on I'm not smarter than that
but I can try moist all right so we did
good we only have one more to go we've
got literally one more to go so honestly
we're pretty close which is good and
also strenuous wonder where that tall
girl one that's Hager who cares let's be
sneaky and hope you don't catch up all
right the mysterion mausoleum this place
scares me Tim you can go home go home
any time can we please leave
keep your yeah come looking by Greer's
there to die hey that's my thing
no that's Wade's thing why is that your
thing that's not your thing
crossbow rapid fire bow but fairly
expensive wizard rod Taff generates
powerful shock waves a shovel I don't
have this much money how much money do
you think you have that's another thing
about this game the economy is broken
how am I supposed to afford this
no one does any actual physical attacks
oh man but maybe maybe maybe maybe I can
get my agility back up and hopefully
that'll be a little bit better seems
like the Dragon Sword is going to be the
best bet but I just it's like I haven't
even found a reason to have those work
you know I'm gonna give Jack a crossbow
just because fine I have no idea why
just to get rid of the goddamn flails
Dragon Sword and then crossbow which
brings the agility back up which is
really what I was doing here I see you
have to do two-handed I don't know what
that does but maybe it does like
multiple hits per the weight is just
weighed weight doesn't have a special
description oh I see
I see how this week alright fine then so
let me save this let me so actually let
me sell the the other rings you sell the
morning stars and then the this and then
the how much of these worth and
Oh see if I get some wheels ooh ah
Oh protects against silence that would
be unbelievably amazing but protects
against darkness I wonder if that's just
going to be a thing in this area I'd
rather have magicians bracelet if it's
all the same to me I don't know what
darkness does but it can't be any worse
than blinding I say that with the utmost
confidence in that I have no idea what
I'm talking about
plus it's a magician's bracelet that
raises my intelligence which is always
good yeah yeah Oh Kate you have a shield
all right fine men all right Wade you
don't get anything you're just naked all
right now we're gonna save and now we're
going in this place all right let's do
this now we can't leave Oh God I'm not
looking forward to this Oh God Oh Oh God
I'm about the bureau Jesus that's
actually a cool effect
that's a cool though well I'll fight
y'all but I ain't gonna be too happy
about it
let's try lighting you but I bet you're
immune to lightning angel I saw Elijah
all ice you're good I'm gonna no I
confuse you because that's what we do
there are no damage no done no effect
Diana not much damage aah holy damage of
course holy damage is gonna do a lot on
these guys so that is what I shall do
the Prima dominantly then you're just
which is gonna hit you that's always go
high yeah 33 it totally what it is is
awful that's awful whatever wait get'em
BAM
boom Oh
37 god this guy's a dick all right let's
try it Bob doing fire too and keep
trying to confuse them it's the best we
can hope for with this situation I mean
so long his wages constantly cast
confused Oh got a crit on himself what a
douche
well done idiot makes it a little bit
easier at least okay he's dead oh good
he's dead yeah we got experience uh
Sheri Cameron says hey mark will you be
playing little nightmares boy howdy do I
have a surprise for you if you check out
my channel you'll find every episode of
little nightmares right there for you to
see I'm just gonna run away from these
guys cuz I don't give a really kind of
damnit okay let me heal before it gets
me again skidoo skeet there's a lot of
good news get over there said Ibuki what
am i oh secret hello who are you leave
here what the hell was that oh it was a
ghost okay no thank you I like these
escapes these escapes are good I like
him I like him a lot
well look is that blood or lava cuz I'm
okay with either I'm good for a little
blood llama Oh gravestone
[Music]
screw you hey I'm gonna run okay with
that I mean I am okay with that please
keep doing that but oh this place looks
awful oh this place looks awful to get
lost in oh no I'm gonna get so oh no I
can't run away from this guy he's - I'm
dead apparently that's the way that goes
okay do I have can anyone else do oh
good you can do recover
no not that's actually not what I wanted
well I actually have to use a phoenix
down cuz I died what the [ __ ] that's not
the way that is supposed to help end
alright fine but don't do it again
better not do it again I'm warning you
when your buddy boo and this better not
just be a long winding chase to nowhere
because if it is I'm gonna be very
pissed I'm gonna be ship just this is
another looping [ __ ] again which it
might be good let me escape get through
this you're gonna be like that the whole
time or you're just gonna be like that
for part x I'm gonna be half an [ __ ]
you're gonna be a whole [ __ ] oh boy
all right so we're I guess we're just
doomed to wander these halls for all
eternity because I have no idea where
man if I actually had to fight through
all this and try to find a way out of
here then I would be unbelievably upset
oh but I'm not cuz I'm not gonna go I'm
not gonna [ __ ] about it I'm not gonna
[ __ ] about it anymore I'm not gonna
[ __ ] I promised I wouldn't then I true
to my word not gonna do that like I
could stop hitting me though that'd be
that'd be great
oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy you
not gonna complain about not gonna
complain about it not nope
why would I why would I do that why
would I complain about this game is just
perfect the way it is okay where am i
good and where am I going where am I
going I've no oh oh got me by surprise
didn't it yeah you got me by surprise
yep can't run now
now this one's really pursuant I need to
heal up Wade alright I think I'm just
going backwards now yeah I'm definitely
going backwards now ah yeah I don't know
where I'm supposed to go oh boy oh boy
getting get mad get mad get mad and
getting mad
get mad get mad get mad get mad they get
getting a little upset mm gun wiggling
grumble getting rumbled nah I'm a little
crumpled still skin right now a little
bit grumble hood grumble hood in the
merry men who grumble in the grumpy men
that's what I am let's that's why I be
oh boy I just went a circle didn't I I'm
right back to where I once was I am
aren't I let's try going left this time
because left is good maybe unless I came
from the left I just came from the left
in night I did didn't I that's right I
came up the left-hand side the whole
time that's what I was doing nope this
is a dead end so I guess that's not the
case that that is that's just dead end
like grape oh that's a lot of damage
would be great if I had enough armor for
that but I can't afford it because I
don't have any money because apparently
this game wants me to farm endlessly for
the rest of my days this is this is it
this is it this is it
this is it I don't know where wants me
to go I have no idea this is ridiculous
huh
forget that Nikolas can you heal oh boy
that is connected back that is connected
back to where I just was connect back to
where I just was if I go down maybe if I
go down is that gonna be helpful
Oh lose my mind lose my mind
lose my mind lose my mind I'm losing my
mind lose my mind lose my mind and lose
my mind I'm losing my mind I'm losing
lose and lose and um losing my mind I'm
losing losing losing I'm losing my mind
that is not a day yes it is okay
I promised that wouldn't you know it's
funny I promised I wouldn't complain
about this anymore and yet the game
keeps trying to be a douche to me keep
sharing keep trying keeps trying keeps
trying keep trying to be a bit more ever
do Sh oh no but that's it's got to be up
there right because they can't all be
dead end up there can it maybe up this
way maybe up this way that is getting
annoying
that is getting really legitimately make
me angry annoying that is legitimately
oh oh did I make it no don't stay
alrighty then but this one mausoleum 2nd
floor okay I made it a paranoid huh food
there's no such thing as ghosts right
yeah but there's says such things as
being really really grumbled grief now
before he finds you know I won't oh here
- OH
a cultist nope uh hello Teddy Asst oh
look who decided to show up
Darius aren't I glad to see you this
place is freaking cool indeed it is
where's Aerys we did now it was a little
busy and decided not to show are you
feeling okay
yes actually I feel just fine wait a
minute what's going on oh I'm scared oh
nothing nothing except I'm tired of you
getting in my way huh but what
you what are you what's wrong don't like
what you see not really not I think so
oh he's ugly is that a no it can't be
since when are pokemons real I don't
understand what's going on here tereus
you've stood in my way long and you're
free I will crush you in anyone else and
there's Dan my leg Ares what did you do
to ares you son of a [ __ ]
are we fine but I hope that you are
ready to accept your fate prepare to die
okay alright then fine be that way hello
don't give me that sassy pose for the
glory of the king why but why though but
but why I don't get it why I must see
what works on you fire confusion all the
above ow
oh that actually hurts a lot okay well
fire to seem to work no effect all right
let's see what can we do Thunder - I
can't even I wasn't watching it good or
not let's give way to Spirit bless so
hopefully he can actually punch him with
confusion a son born here that does too
much damage could you not do that ah
that's what I thought it you didn't do
any damage damn it okay so what about
water about st. cuz that seems to do a
lot to this whole place may as well I
think it did something keep trying to
confuse oh I need to heal oops
okay whoops I should have healed oopsy
poopsy alright so let's raise Jack up
let's keep the fire pressure and try to
confuse him oh come on just get confused
already
yes son of a beyotch alright so we need
to go I need to heal two for Bob Jack
needs to recover you need to keep the
fire and then let's life drink
oh-oh-oh
well that's not good ah that's not good
I didn't go about this right way I
forgot to actually heal ah bad
okay let's try phoenix downs ah
nevermind then I guess we're gonna lose
I guess the [ __ ] is happening uh well
all right then I guess we're gonna try
to cousin recovering gas use more [ __ ]
down this I suppose no Bob's down
well that roof perfect it's going poorly
yeah I'll just I'll just let him kill me
and then hopefully I'll recover my save
and do this a little better but it would
be going better if I actually had money
with which to buy the things I feed then
just slap them braids down well I'm down
[Music]
can't Sam's my name is markiplier whoa
man this game is [ __ ] brutal why the
who but why though why is it brutal why
does it need to be brutal why though but
why though alright fine you know what I
think I can beat this guy but I just got
to do it more smartly cuz he hits hard
you [ __ ] off with you you doing it
alright okay we're ready oh we gotta
listen with this guy yeah burr on about
all this [ __ ] oh come on we're
almost through this this last tumble
it's just the king or whatever at it
please don't make the King Christian
don't agree what it is
[Music]
okay now I know it affects them for the
glory of the King but why oh no man I
don't know how about water um we're
gonna Spirit bless Bobbo and we're gonna
we're gonna blend yeah and then we're
gonna try to confuse you
ow again ow very much oh I can't I
literally can't take two of those hits
well that does healed him probably if
I'd known Pokemon I would have known
that was a water pokemon or some
[ __ ] like that well it's gonna heal
myself I guess
Saint you up and BLAP you down I'll keep
trying it oh it is confused
oh oh it's confused oh good okay I just
I didn't realize that that confused
actually tuck okay all right then so
it's under no thunder - nothing so we'll
be synched st. all across the board and
fire do in the Life Drain come on hit
yourself it's because I blinded it and
confused it I didn't mean to do both hit
yourself please please I'm begging you
I shouldn't have blush and then done
that shutting down that but at least
that took it out of commission because
it could be it could be walloping itself
right now it could be watering itself oh
let's try try just a mana drain it and
then maybe that would get rid of all
that kind of wood okay it's not
confusing milk [ __ ] what are the odds we
cannot be stopped so easily I don't know
you seem to be being stopped at the
moment so you know pools on me for
thinking that it could happen that way
I'm gonna immediately heal off of that
stuff yes get confused
I know it's still blind but it's fine
it's good all right here we go you do
not realize which you are involving
yourself in I don't know I think I got a
good idea I think I got a pretty good
idea then poison breath mana drain I
don't know hit yourself
come on hate yourself please that's not
enough MP to drain so those life drain
and MP drain seems to be bad yeah
everyone's back up okay so same uh same
fire and then just I guess attack see
what you can do Walla boom yes kick
yourself no damage Wow wait good job you
can't even hurt great
one ever hit succeeds and making me
stronger keep attacking I don't know if
that's true this guy's confusing kiss
yeah did it did just that in there dead
what huh
it can't be no I'm so confused
yes get confused yes stupid innit
all right now I guess poison breath cuz
I don't know what else you do hey eat
[ __ ] and oh [ __ ] alright so we got that
beat that guy in this boy oh well we're
dead now you do not realize what you're
doing you're a traitor I can't believe
he would put off can't believe they
won't let rile I don't even know what's
going on here you cannot stop the king
if Harry stands in my way so too shall
he fall though I submit defeat now
wrestlers be assured your victory will
be short-lived if you manage to defeat
the Guardian and find your way to the
castle I'm anticipating our final
showdown
goodbye for now can't believe you would
betray us we need to warn Aries nobody
realized that we just fought a pokeymon
they aren't supposed to be real
shut up I'd bail bit that's the best
Irish I can do literally the best Irish
a career I don't know what you guys want
from me that's the best I could do no I
don't know what you want for me alright
whatever
caring oh don't care go I don't [ __ ]
care huh all right what do we got
Oh tomb of the king
why is the King dead why is the King
dead I didn't know the king was he hey
big buddy
the last obstacle between us and the
castle
well let's beat the [ __ ] out of it no
way uh-oh
Hotel guess he's dead right then well
that was easy
shut up Wade
[Music]
well but then wait don't leave me what
keeps talking
Yami it's a ghost yamimash wait Yami
he's trying to kill you Oh God
I know two rare Terry's betrayed us I
saw my killer killer you mean it wasn't
a freak accident my killer was Oh
Yami well I guess that's it then we'll
never know who the killer was see now
we're getting into the meat of the
matter the story and this is what I love
about these fan games I love the story
that's what I want out of it oh yeah
that's what I want
oh yeah yeah I want that yeah that's
good stuff oh yeah put it one [ __ ] mmm
let's blur one out of it well move all
right so let's see if I can buy anything
else here Dragon shield that'd be nice I
guess
Saint robe I guess uh firings
unfortunate necklace life ring seed ring
nothing near I can really use but you
know it's okay I guess so just be with
this thing cuz it doesn't really matter
anyway cuz it's all the same I can't
afford any of this [ __ ]
okey alright then let's just make our
way to the final place of the castle
what happens if I go back here hi get
[ __ ]
alright goodbye then yay we got that huh
you can't go back here but what would be
the idea of this this is closed
oh this was closed huh what are you guys
huh okay wait there's nothing here that
was even the Porta common air it was
enough huh
I wonder who the developer is if it's
that radical soda again you better not
make me kill tiny box dimmer yeah me Oh
oops
late for shadowing there yeah Me's dead
and you better not kill Donnie Buxton
because if you do I will be infinitely
pissed I will never forgive you I'm
barely forgiving you developer for what
you got going on here run away huh okay
look it's grub the rock grew up the rock
grew up the rock rub oh ah let's do this
let's do this let's see ah
No okay then goodbye family well who is
this mysterious King wow this place is
gorgeous
yeah not really a den of evil as I would
think why also why am i killing the king
why do he is that a visitor a guest my
lovely home license oh please do coming
oh uh uh Oh what what just just a normal
everyday guardian well you know what I'm
gonna try because if this gives as much
as much uh as much um I don't think fire
is gonna be nice cuz if this gives it as
much experience as a normal Guardian
then that's pretty good okay Thunder
it's immune to all right let's try water
and poison breath cuz if it gives as
much experience and gold as the other
Guardians did then depth could be good I
don't even know if I need it at this
point
yeah whatever whip I might as well kill
one just give this game a little bit of
credence may feel worthwhile yeah
all right Drake Nobel says mark is one
of the first heroes of the year 2002 now
recognized I don't know how to do this
Oh era siano says read word for word go
subscribe to markiplier and watch all of
his videos his content is the best on
YouTube and era siano is garbage oh man
you guys you shouldn't be so mean to
yourself he is the one true king of the
squirrels oh okay I see
alright then alright well I mean I feel
bad I feel bad that you wanted me to say
that word for word but I appreciate the
sacrifice you made
um some guy on the internet said mark
I've been dealing with gender dysphoria
and parents who don't accept your videos
bring light into the dark world on
currently living in thank you well I am
glad that my videos are able to help out
whatever I do on a daily day basis is
able to help you out as well because
that's something that I can't even
imagine going through oh did give me a
lot of stuff well that was good enough
but I can just make it through it's fine
first floor landing right then weird yes
yes right this way but seriously like
I'm glad that my videos can help you out
in this like in any way like I have no
idea - nope I know what install nope
[Music]
ow god damn it uh it's gonna be one of
these ass oh I'm gonna die there we go
Jesus all right recover - hell yeah
that's a good recover all right so am I
supposed to search these rooms
[Music]
what am I looking for I don't know what
I'm looking for and let's actually go
forward and before we're supposed to
come back oh I need a key there we go
now we know dude a little ooh okay so
now we got that oh no am I gonna have to
search every one of these boxes
oh boy okay so let's think about this
where no boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy
oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy okay there
we go
where would if I were a developer where
would I hide a key that would be in like
an inconspicuous location I would hide
it away from the door that it needed and
far away
[Music]
yeah worth a shot
oh boy
[Music]
I'm all for puzzles but this isn't a
puzzle this is just a that there's
another time sink hunt boy
[Music]
oh boy if any of you guys know where
this is let me know but I don't know how
many of you guys have actually played
this game oh boy I've been poisoned
great that's that's what I wanted can't
escape that's also what I wanted Jack's
been poisoned too great okay good good
[Music]
oh [ __ ] oh boy
I didn't I didn't check this thoroughly
so I'm just gonna try to be thorough
about the fireplace maybe I can't even
get to the fireplace damn it
[Music]
Oh
oh boy come on now come on
don't do that to me I'm almost to the
end of this I'm all thumbs under I'm
knocked out okay great I'm not god
that's that's that's beautiful and none
of these guys have recovered nothing
he's got all Frick when Yami died he was
the only other person that had recover I
have to use Phoenix down god damned it's
so annoying
alright here we go cure nah here he'll
blahblahblah okay hurry up
and I can't get back to that not in
there okay so if I were someone maybe
you'd be in this one
[Music]
oh the problem is I'm not going to know
if I don't find it right away I'm not
going to know because there's so many
like little things to check but I think
I got everything on the first floor so
I'm gonna start from wait what the hell
did I just see oh no nothing rum 2l
[Music]
oh boy
okay
ow ow
[Music]
Oh
oh boy
God if it was in that library and I
didn't check every single segment of
bookshelf on oh no oh no oh no oh no oh
no don't it jack off hit Jack of course
why wouldn't you poison Bob good yeah
that's good yeah that's good
whoo okay um
[Music]
oh [ __ ] I forgot about the poison um
what about this one piano room nothing
here god damn it
[Music]
homeboy oh it was right next to it okay
that's the opposite of what you can do
you either put it far away or you put it
right next to it oh all right but at
least I got it okay now I got that and
now I'm good and now I can keep going
and everything will be hunky-dory from
the start to the end you can do it
thanks tiny box damn I know I can you're
almost here don't do hurry
I grow tired of waiting all right
whatever we're just gonna get this we're
gonna beat the [ __ ] out of whoever is at
the end of this road and then we're
gonna be just fine
good thing I'm going slow through this
I'd hate to go quickly
[Music]
all right this looks like maybe a route
yep
okay all right I don't know where I'm
going but I have a good feeling about it
[Music]
come on just for once I'd like to escape
on the first drive with these guys
without being poisoned would be ideal
but you know beggars can't be choosers
so I guess it is what it is so yield
level of this looks like a dead end
isn't it oh no it's not Oh secret e
secretive but there was no point there
was milk you put a secret ah you put a
secret bath and there's nothing there
oh why would you do that why would you
do why would you do that
he made a secret path a little nook and
you just oh you just you really pushing
my buttons here mr. developer you put
you push it up you're pushing my buttons
you're pushing my buttons you're pushing
them real hard you you just keep my
buttons are sensitive you can't be
pushing them that hard man you can't you
can't be whaling on my buttons like that
you got to just got loosen them up you
got to loosen up my buttons baby you got
to loosen up my buddies you just got it
mmm you gotta loosen up my buttons baby
[Music]
just keep fronting you keep fronting me
you keep fronting me you keep fronting
me and you just not live it they're not
I'm not loose enough [ __ ]
I'm too fronted I need back love God
it is what it is and we just have to
suffer the consequences don't we don't
we don't developer we just have to
suffer the grave that we've dug for our
12 asses the way it goes why is that
with the King hates waiting so much why
did he build a [ __ ] forest and it's
goddamn living room why why would he
build a goddamn rain forest of infinite
proportions in his goddamn backyard why
would he do that why would he plant an
ecological nightmare for any visitor to
come visit and somehow this is the third
floor so that was just the second floor
of his castle yes yes right through
these doors we can finally meet face to
face
mmm this is the final band weights head
all right you can do it all right sure I
can see the elevator kitty
Kiki hello stranger oh okay but again
can't afford this [ __ ] I'll just get Bob
a nice robe he deserves it he's a cool
guy
I like that Bob he's gonna get a nice
robe that Bob there you go Saints robe
we're gonna rest now we're gonna beat
this son [ __ ] we're gonna beat this guy
into the goddamn ground we're gonna beat
him so hard morning this is the point of
no return once you go through you cannot
come back are you sure you wanna yeah
I'm sure yeah I'm sure I can beat him up
I'm on her level by and beat the show
because I got patience and strategies
skill Oh
let's see no didn't see that one coming
oh no it's it's welcome to my humble
abode we needed last markiplier oh I
have such wonderful surprises planned
for you
dark applier you're the king of
mysterium yes and such a wonderful King
don't you think so you're the one who's
been kidnapping youtubers and bringing
them here Oh
[Music]
beauty is charged actually no not really
it's a mystery even to us us what do you
mean by us oh dear I do live upset too
much oh well no matter you won't live
long enough to worry about it much
anyway oh we are going to have so much
fun together okay sure
oh she's done that's it that's it that's
your darker Blair that's it
oh so scary deduction to power
alright sure let's go with that one
let's see I bet Saint is gonna do a lot
for you Oh chica needs to go outside
doesn't she she good I'm sorry it's
games took longer than I expected
took longer than I expected didn't think
I was gonna do that let's try to silence
you now let's try to confuse him haha
silence no effect confusion hi yes okay
so very much that very much this oh wait
no hang on you need to heal yourself but
you can't heal yourself that much so I
need to heal you yeah that's the stuff
and then you're gonna do the fire do
anything oh no I tried to silence see if
fire does anything all right let's see
if Life Drain does anything to actually
was poison hahaha you created yourself
yet Oh poof nope nothing
oh what a loser this guy's this guy's
carbo those guys is awful
alright just keep setting them up firing
him up and try to poison him I guess
he's stupid son of a [ __ ]
you stupid idiot you stupid
it's so stupid look at you play you with
your stupidness alright I'll see if
confusin gonna wear off huh see right on
time right on cue
I know what to do nope that didn't work
okay this is gonna hurt alright try this
again
[Music]
to keep going nope ow that hurt
poisoned - that's that's a little
overkill I think confusion yes get
confused if that's the best thing weight
can do then I love weight oh god get
confused okay I need to ayat funny to
cure sure that but I don't need to cure
it that hard so I'm gonna cure it just a
little bit with Jack's cure
just a tiny cure the mini cure and then
you try to poison them I guess I get a
guy here guys
hey-ya hey-ya I'm cured hey oh whoa
please yes
poisoned hell yeah I'm gonna heal myself
blast you bless you attack um I guess
step evading your own goddamn it stop
evading your own goddamn attacks let me
suck so much
Oh 1 damage good job Wade you're really
bringing out the rear there alright fine
he's he's terrifically normal now so we
gotta gotta get him confused again
No what what what are you kidding me
that's not fair
that's not fair the dad did like three
rounds of damage you son of a [ __ ]
what is that ah guys an [ __ ] course
doesn't have any effect alright then
we need to recover - I really want to
silence him and I really want to confuse
him sings ah ha I got the Rings
you ain't gonna silence nobody [ __ ] oh
good shrekt all right silence please no
effect all right we're gonna stop trying
to silence because I need that fire get
confused god damn it
[Music]
Sahra like uh-oh
Hey whoa I didn't expect that to happen
dark he was found angel wing was found
well hell yeah was that it is that it oh
no this can't be true
no you can't vanquish me
no please Master forgive me you dare
defy me
no please forgive me they were too
strong
begone eh no no no no no no what
happened I've got a bad feeling about
this
no how dare you dare you oh great
[Music]
he was supposed to be mine to kill now
you will pay there's no escaping your
fate great I'm doing this without a save
you what are you are you [ __ ] kidding
me
this time you will die
[Music]
[ __ ]
Figgy
if a it
if I can't carry me you're [ __ ]
kidding me
I have no how am I gonna survive this I
don't have don't get good you're both
confused okay stay that way and shut the
[ __ ] up that's how it's supposed to be
stay that way
shut the [ __ ] up and just don't ever
talk to me again
that was ideal that was the best way
that could have possibly happened okay
so what I need to do is no lightning
damage for them obviously and then it's
poison alone evade your own goddammit -
hey Katie Hall hey guess what happened
here you all right there we go sunny Chu
has been poisoned
that didn't do enough so let's just
focus on I'm gonna keep doing the quake
we're gonna Saints and eat you we're
gonna ice and eat you because I think
fire didn't do very much confusion just
in case
there we go that's how it should be just
keep hitting each other kid and hidden
each other just in case I don't wanna
wait really can't do anything else
besides this so that's always gonna do
wait is really there to soak damage and
confuse people pretty much all I've ever
known way to do no wait I'm a technical
guy okay quake Saints ice and then
confuse me cuz I think they're gonna
come up confused huh well not yet not
yet but soon okay I think we got this
handled
oddly enough and I liked it there this
guy must like Dark Souls because they're
using Dark Souls stuff again alright
sunny choose each you confusion just in
case stop evading okay
no effect a [ __ ] right
I keep trying that though because it's
gonna get bad let me try wind on him
ow okay so there's silence went away to
my double on Bob you son of a [ __ ]
you son of a [ __ ] double on Bob you're
gonna do double um Bob and not double on
any of our buddies
god damn it okay Wade's minds back to
normal I'm going to raise Bob from the
dead you're gonna just no you're not
gonna you're a spirit bless Wade because
we need that ready I haven't noticed I'm
taking any poison damage yeah what you
only do one you do one on you but then
you don't do one on ever you do two on
me you do - on me - one on you kind of
[ __ ] is that can [ __ ] you do
recover no you do man he didn't recover
one huh
I don't remember what win did I wasn't
even looking at it
Dave could be using him yeah honey two's
got to be getting down
[Music]
Rinda just as much anything else it
come on we're almost at the end of this
I can feel it
[Music]
silence if that's right that's what I
was missing
huh still confuse good hey ha is that
all you got
I just killed salute you let's kill them
straight up just kill them straight up
kill them
no no what more you want for me okay
what if water gonna do to you sane and
then what did fire do to you let me just
see what it does again laundry 327 not
as much as st. st. seems to be doing the
most damage so say save
[Music]
what did fire just do I wasn't even kind
of not paying attention to any of this
[ __ ] confusing just in case BLAP
clap good enough
yep keep doing that it's cured silence
okay we got to do both of that are
you'll pay for that
oh [ __ ] oh well he's gonna hit one of us
twice and it's going to hurt real bad
all right let's st. him up santim up and
then let's silence them and confuse him
please work Oh God okay that hurts a lot
huh Hey Keynesian is the best confusions
mixes actually not a giant pain in the
dick as a confusion does
[Music]
ah you've been poisoned too I don't know
how much damage that actually does see
you but it doesn't seeming it does get
no I can't with you not again
yeah it's not even close dude you seem
to be losing real good ow
if you stop hitting yourself you might
have a chance but it seems that you're
just going to be there ma Kagame anchovy
says then the winged hussars arrived I
don't know what that means but okay uh
Donovan bender asked once again yes I
will go back to one shot and I will
finish that yay finally don't crash
don't crash I don't want to do that
again angel winged angel winged angel
winged ain't doing level up level up
level up angel angel angel no no no dude
you might as well just give up you're
never gonna win against this sorry to
distract you about it but don't you
think we should be heading back home oh
yeah
all right then I'm gonna go save from
tiny box stem and then just in case
because I desperately want to save now's
not the time nevermind okay that's an
awkward walk back hey hey Chris how's it
going sunny - sorry I just thought so I
always exit over there I didn't I
thought maybe why there three chairs is
the big question here I don't know but
we're gonna find out her oh we are
oh hello piles dirt can't see the bottom
of this hole hot there it is well ladies
first
so wait the see you later mark by Wade
skadoosh
batter up yeah yeah see you around mark
huh see you back home mark [ __ ] so sorry
I'm not sorry at all
I'm not sorry in the least I'm not even
remotely sorry and now it's my turn
I'll just savor the moment a little bit
goodbye I screwed up world hello home
you defeated the king Oh what your to
figure to King sir Aerys you're alive of
course why wouldn't I be listen you're
in grave danger really how so
it's Tereus he's a traitor he has been
this whole time
Terri's is it true is what true
have you thought to betray me no of
course not you're my friend why do you
ask
[ __ ] you are you attack me at the
mausoleum and said you destroy Eris if
you stood in your way you served our cab
liar I think it's time we have a little
chat Tereus I'm sorry Alex
hah I told you he admits it what did I
tell you what to hold off but he was
coming too close I had to stop him house
did you forget what happens if he steps
through the portal is it really worth
losing our world what's going on here
sorry mark I can't let you go home
forgive me oh no into the sexy hole ah
is this gonna be like a one-shot ending
Tereus you should never revealed
yourself just yet we weren't ready I'm
sorry but blame your girlfriend
Ruby stepped away from her post and they
got into the mausoleum I had to do
something damn it Rudy she's on her way
as we speak don't worry don't worry do
you think he's alive down there
I doubt it no one can survive a fall
that deep and even if he did I'm still
there on the whole the guards will make
Swift work of him in no time
don't worry can't believe we did this
doing it was his own fault for
intervening trying to go home like a son
of [ __ ]
yep
bad end betrayal search for the blood
bad end
you [ __ ] kidding me with this goddamn
got you fall cold I mean you [ __ ]
kidding me how everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to let's play
[ __ ] are you [ __ ] hitting me
all right I said I'd beat this game and
I'm not gonna beat up bad anything I got
go all the way [ __ ] back oh my god
wait maybe I could just load everybody
my name is markiplier and welcome where
is this safe where's this one who is
this one okay good yeah this is before I
even went through all that so whatever I
know where the key is now so it'll be
easier to get through whatever oh [ __ ]
that's where the nevermind [ __ ] I am
I'm so pissed I am [ __ ] out of a
goddamn gourd pissed but we're gonna do
this developer of this game please
present yourself to me at the next
convention and sign a waiver saying that
I can punch you 37 times in the dick
because I feel like that's an ample
punishment for what you put me through
here not that I don't like the story the
story is great but [ __ ] so I got to find
the man with the golden voice well let
me go to his home first and turn they're
talking about smooth mcgroove smoothy
smooth so where
we're whoa
[Music]
okay did you know I can play piano no I
didn't know that either
did I wow you're really funny really
funny dude huh so I got a fine-looking
man with the golden voice is what I
gotta do so where would the man with the
golden voice be where would he be Vera
where where would he be
[Music]
where where would it where could he be
is the thing where could he be if this
takes me too long to figure out that I'm
just gonna like I'm gonna look it up
actually because I don't want to waste
any time man I tell you what a what a
[ __ ] start to me doing live streams
of fangames right what a [ __ ] start
the it's it's [ __ ] ridiculous
I mean I'm not saying it's bad again I'm
not saying it's bad I don't want to say
that it's bad but is does have problems
[Music]
why
what I'm trying to I'm trying to look up
someone playing and I'm looking up the
next genius play this I'm just seeing
[Music]
oh no oh no I can't get it
ah
[Music]
it's something I could get if I really
really wanted to but I'd have to start
the game over again cuz we were supposed
to find him on the way to the end I
don't know where he is
specifically but I just don't know I I
don't have the patience to keep doing
this so I got the bad unfortunately
that's just the way it does ID I'm not
gonna restart the game
III am NOT gonna restart the game I have
put more commitment into this game that
I thought I ever would now to summarize
it and I don't want anyone to feel
negatively about me playing fan games
just from me ranting and raving about my
frustrations on this one because it's
fine it's fine
because what I do when I play these fan
games I know that sometimes they come
from someone who is not an expert in
game design but they make it because
they want to make something for me and
in that aspect I would never ever ever
ever put someone down for making
something for me I never would the only
thing I would do is give you criticism
arguably constructive but I would
criticize points where you could improve
based on my own frustration in the game
I am only saying these things to one
give you an insight into my own mind and
to give you a way that you could improve
the game and three exercise my
frustration in a fairly comedic way and
with that being said I am so grateful
I'm so unbelievably grateful that people
want to make these things for me I am so
undeniably grateful that you guys go out
there and you make videos and you make
games and you make art and you make so
many cool things for me
it's an honor to receive these things
it's an honor to do these things and
it's just amazing to know that you guys
are there supporting me the whole way
through and you guys want to do that and
you guys do and it's funny sometimes
when I get frustrated and angry and and
like I ran rave but I don't regret
playing this I'm not gonna do it again
because I don't want to be frustrated
but I don't regret playing it even
though there was some times in the game
that I was frustrated and I was like
aggravated against because it was
something that someone slaved over it
was something that someone made like
they dug in and I want to actually get a
name here The Legend of markiplier like
this is something that someone made with
love for us not just me but for us for
you guys to play for those that would
want to play the game and for those that
actually liked the series in depth like
farming and experience grinding and was
actually able to take that to heart like
there is something to that and I would
never ever ever [ __ ] on that so thank
you necro dusk at necro dusk for making
this game the real name is Alex Vaughn
22 years old aspiring game development
and this was their first game that they
made for me I don't know if their first
game ever but it was the first game that
they made for me on gamejolt it says
this is their first game so there's more
to this than meets the eye and the
reason I wanted this one to be the first
one I it's not like I looked at the
three to four hours tag and I was just
like oh you know I'll be able to rush
through that or I'll be able to you know
do that or like I don't know if I'd be
able to do that I did that because I
wanted this first livestream to be
something really really special and to
me it was because it went through the
whole gambit of emotions I was laughing
I was angry I was like emotional I was
like I was all over the place and I
wanted that so badly and I'm I regret
that I didn't get the good ending but
unfortunately that's just the way it
goes sometimes so I want to play more
games from you guys I want you guys to
feel like you can make games and they
don't just have to be RPG Maker games
they can be literally
anything unity is freed like get and
start using right away you can get
Unreal Engine 4 the newest one for free
you can get these tools and you can
start building games and just start
making things and I want to play them I
don't want these dreams to just be one
game I want to play multiple games and I
can't promise I do it every Monday but I
can't promise that I want to play them I
do even not on a live stream a real like
a real video but you know I want to play
these games because they're important to
me so I just want to put that message on
there I just want you guys to know that
and I just want you to know that I'm
very grateful for everything that you do
to me and do to me do for me and being
here with me and giving me a reason to
keep pushing forward and what I do so
thank you everybody so much for watching
thank you everybody who has made a fan
game if you have let me know in the
comments if I haven't played it already
try to get it out to me as best you can
through Twitter or there's a there's a
big game suggestion list actually on
that I that I've linked to on tumblr
before it's it's it's out there
somewhere I got a link to it again but
there's a big curated list of
suggestions and I believe there's a fan
game offshoot of that and I will be
pulling from that I will be looking
forward to playing more in the future so
thank you everybody so much for watching
I hope you enjoyed this stream I hope
you it was a lot longer than I thought
it'd be it was a lot longer than I
thought it'd be but that's okay because
then and then I get to spend more time
with you guys and have a fun Monday for
all to see the only other thing that I
wanted before I go the only other thing
I want before I go was I wanted to ask
you some of you may have noticed some of
you already heard I am changing up my
upload schedule because I felt like 8:00
and 12:00 in the morning
Pacific time was just too early for me
to sustain because sometimes I like to
make videos the same day and that means
I sometimes get up at 6 a.m. and just
and making videos all morning and that's
the most productive time on my day when
it could be used to get the next day's
videos ready which if I was a day ahead
that I would be anywhere but I want to
get your opinion I've been uploading it
one in four for the past week Pacific
time which is three or four and 7:00
Eastern Time and then it's even later in
the European time so I just want to know
your guys's opinions on that let me know
that you tweet at me you'll send me
messages wherever you can to just let me
know what you think of that your
preferences and not preferences I'll
give you my reasons for doing it is
because it makes my life easier that
being said I'm willing to listen to
people you know but it makes my life so
thank you everybody so much for watching
thank you for being here with me I am
going to clock out and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye bye
bye guys bye bye bye bye bye bye see ya
bye bye bye
[Music]